Auf gehts! Leute, kann das sein, dass wir letzte Woche, was heißt wir, in dem Fall garantiert
nicht wir, sondern nur ich, letzte Woche fünfmal am Start waren? Ist ja, was ist denn da los?
Guckt euch das mal an. Eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf. Beziehungsweise mit dem hier fünf,
je nachdem, ob man den Sonntag mitrechnet oder den Sonntag mitrechnet. Fünfmal, wir waren
fünfmal on. Fünf, fünf Streams in der Woche, das ist ja für meine Verhältnisse fast jeden Tag.
Oder für meine Verhältnisse fast regelmäßig durch das Mahnen. Was ich ja faszinierend finde,
dass ausgerechnet ich hasse C++ so viele Zuschauer. Kann ich aber auch verstehen. C++
sackt. Das will jeder sehen, wie C++ geflammt wird. Aber das ist fast regelmäßig Sachen gibt's.
Anscheinend hat es doch seinen Vorteil, wenn man Homeoffice macht und direkt daheim ist.
Erster, wupp wupp, POG. Kleinschreib-Emote-Leute am Start. Obwohl ich ja nicht, ich hab hier gar
kein Emote, kein FFZ und Gedöns installiert. Doch, ich muss FFZ installiert haben. Hab ich,
da ist doch da. DefrancaZ ist installiert. Ja, aber Leute, jetzt wo ihr gerade hier am Start seid,
ich hab's grad schon gesagt. Guckt mal, ich hab fast sowas wie regelmäßig gestreamt
letzte Woche. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 Streams. Oder 5, je nachdem, welchen Sonntag man mitrechnet.
Wie heißt das Plugin? Volumemaster oder so. Ja, Volumemaster. Ich hab einfach das Plugin
genommen, was die beste Bewertung im Shop hatte. Keine Ahnung, ob das irgendwelche Backdoors enthält
oder so. Exzellent. Aber wir verlassen uns mal auf die strengen Qualitätskontrollen im Google App
Store, im Chrome App Store. Da kann überhaupt nichts drin sein. Ich hatte mir ja mal einen
Addon eingefangen mit Backdoor. Und zwar hieß das Copper Everywhere. Das war ein Plugin,
kein Emote. Es war ein Plugin, das auf jeder Seite Twitch Emotes anzeigt. Und das wurde dann von
irgendwelchen Chinesen übernommen und hatte Backdoors drinne. Exzellent. Also sprich, da
bringt das auch nichts, wenn man das aus dem offiziellen App Store installiert. Das kann da
genauso passieren. Also bei Google guckt ja auch niemand von Hand den Kram durch. Vielleicht bei
besonders populären Extensions. Aber ansonsten guckt da keiner den Kram durch. Ich muss grad
mal mein Fragen-Board wieder neu starten. So, Exzellent PP-Board. Was steht heute an? Aufwachen.
Erstmal die Fragen von gestern löschen. Benutzst du deine Waage mit Körper? Ja, ja. Jeden Tag fast.
Sport, mega null. Nextcloud versus oncloud, Nextcloud. Aktuelles Buch. Ja, immer noch das
gleiche. Chat, ich muss euch mal übrigens neu laden. Chat, ich muss euch neu laden. Ich seh
nämlich die Zuschaueranzahl grad nicht. Ah, yes, exzellent. Jetzt geht's. Elevencore ist auch am Start.
Also, C-Sharp-Buch kann ich immer nur das da, das da recommenden. Das hier. Das ist gut,
das ist kostenlos und damit hab ich 2002 oder so auch angefangen. Nee, nee. Kommt FFmpeg aus
Frankfurt. Das ist tatsächlich eine wahnsinnige PP-Ga-Frage. Freue mich echt auf Dortnet 5 ja,
ich auch. Außer der Benahmung, was dann wieder bei Microsoft abgehen wird. Good.
Kannst du mal die Seite von denen zeigen? Ich find das gar nicht. Seite von wem? Schon schon
verdrängt, um was es ging. Der Cal, der macht wohl nur Top-Nintendo-Songs, oder? Top 1000
Nintendo-Songs, Top 300 Nintendo-Songs. Ich würde jetzt mal vermuten, dass die Top 300
Nintendo-Songs eigentlich in den Top 1000 Nintendo-Songs dabei sein müssten. Würde
man jetzt vermuten. Aber anscheinend ist das zu big brain. Heute erst mal gelesen,
dass erneut irgendein One-Line-GS-Package alles prägt. Echt? NPM? Muss ich mal gleich gucken.
Welches? Welches? Welches? Ah, hier. Ach, keine Malware, sondern irgendwas, was es kaputt
macht, weil einer unterm anderen Namen wieder gepusht hat oder so. One-Line-NPM-Package
is broke. NPM ist so kaputt. NPM ist so kaputt. Die Musik. Epischer Chor für NPM Break. Mein
zweites Windows hat mir gerade ein Pop-Up rausgehauen. Windows 10 Update Assistant is already running.
Ah ja, exellent. Ich hab ihn zwar nicht gestartet, aber es ist gut zu wissen, dass der already
running ist. Da bin ich ja froh. So, ähm. Hehe. It's broken serverless. Leute, wie kann
ein GS-Package denn serverless broken? Da hat man doch gar keinen Server. Das geht doch
gar nicht. Vielleicht mal wieder ein Hinweis, für dass serverless absolut eine Kackname
ist. Doch, moin. Und warum geht das kaputt? Warum breakt das? Kann ja nicht irgendjemand
erklären, der bisschen fitter mit JavaScript ist. Warum breakt das? Warum hat das alles
kaputt gemacht? Ich check's grad nicht. Was ist da kaputt? MXPuppetSkype. Check ich nicht.
Warum macht das alles kaputt? Hat der irgendeine Funktion doppelt definiert? Ich verstehe
JavaScript manchmal. Manchmal hat die Logik nicht. Ähm. Zumindest ist man wieder die
Sache im Arsch. Nice. Ach, ist das, ach, jetzt versteh ich's. Ist das so ein Ding,
ist das so ein Ding, ähm, wo alle, was alle als Dependency haben? Also das ist, das ist
quasi so ein Ding, was 30 Milliarden Sachen als Dependency haben und, ähm, der hat eine
neue Version gepusht, die kaputt ist. Seh ich das richtig? Ja, selbst schuld. Dann legt
das gar nicht mal in NPM. Das ist dann, das ist dann halt einfach selbst schuld. Außerdem,
warum locken die nicht die Version auf irgendwas und testen's mal bevor sie's upgraden? JavaScript,
was auch immer. Muss ich mich jetzt nicht näher mit Beschäftigen im Detail. Tritt
man nur, tritt man nur durch im Kopf. Ähm. Ja, wie gesagt hier. Nochmal jetzt wo ein paar
mehrere Leute da sind. Wir haben fast regelmäßig gestreamt hier, aber auch auf fünfmal. Poggers.
Äh, kannst du mal die Seite von denen zeigen? Ich hab schon wieder vergessen um was es geht.
Was ging's? Ich guck jetzt auch in Chat. Was ging's? Äh, wer walt's weh schreibt das Problem
hab ich seit gestern Abend auch. Ja, ich hab wahrscheinlich, wie gesagt, 3,4 Repos hängen
davon ab. Der Umut schreibt, ich brauch dein Rat, ich hab ein NAS. Oh, der Michael Fünft
Billionen ist auch am Start. Billiarden oder was auch immer, große Zahl. Äh, ich brauch
dein Rat. Ich hab ein NAS wo ich per Akronis Backup, auch das hab ich schon ewig schon
mal verwendet. Akronis Backup drauf Spiele will nun per Windows. Irgendwie die Backups
nach draußen auf meinen Server schieben kannst. Ja, kann ich. Kenn ich das da. Perfekt. Also
wenn du sie in die Cloud schieben willst ist das top. Beste. Airclone unterstützt alle
diese Cloud Provider. Du kannst einfach einfach zünden. Das ist das beste Tool dafür. Ansonsten
wenn du sowohl den Server bei dir als auch deinen Backup Server im Internet kontrollierst
dann mach einfach einen R-Sync und gut ist. Restig ist auch ganz gut. 50 Millionen hast
du nachgerechnet? Oder was hast gerechnet? Gezählt? Zeig mal her. Das müssen wir jetzt
mal kontrollieren. 1, 2, 3. 1, 2, 3. 500 Millionen sind es nun gar keine Billiarden.
Da brauchst du noch ein paar. Das ist garantiert Splatoon Musik. So hört es schon so an.
Ok fast. Es ist Mario Kart 8 Splatoon Musik. Bin ja nicht der Einzige der findet das die
Splatoon Musik übelst nervig ist. Und mir war ja damals schon klar als ich den allerersten
Trailer zum allerersten Splatoon gesehen hab. Leute mir war es damals ja schon klar. Ich
muss es wahrscheinlich gar nicht aussprechen was mir klar war. Und ja das gibt's. Das
war mir als ich den allerersten Trailer gesehen hab schon komplett klar. Genau dann bin ich
ja ganz erkannt. Warum hast du so viele Tabs auf weil die sich mit der Zeit angesammelt
haben? So also mit der Seite habe ich schon wieder verpeilt was es ging. Hat mal beantwortet.
Was denkst du zu Zertifikaten? So genau das eigentlich. Ich denke zu Zertifikaten je
nach Bereich. Und ob die jeweiligen Arbeitgeber drauf gucken kann das sinnvoll sein. Aber
ich persönlich aber ich bin ja auch nicht in der Position. Ich würde nicht nach Zertifikaten
gehen. Zertifikate die tatsächlich ein bisschen was aussagen würde ich sagen ist so die richtig
hohen Cisco Dinger. Die sagen zumindest aus dass du nicht der totale Versager mit Cisco
Geräten bist. Also wenn du. Wie heißt die höchste Cisco aus von Zertifikat Internet
Engineer oder? Ich glaube das ist CCIE Internet Engineer. Ich glaube das ist die höchste
oder eine der höchsten. Wenn du die hast bist du auf jeden Fall ziemlich pro was Cisco
hat wie angeht. Warum zeigst du nicht auch dein Gesicht? Weil ich das seit 10 Jahren
auch auf YouTube nicht mache und ich keinen Bock hab dass ich morgens in der Bahn setze.
Und Leute sagen ey Max was geht alle? Schnell meine Ruhe. Hat Microsoft nicht so ziemlich
alle Zertifikate eingestellt? Weiß ich nicht. Ich hab irgendwas gelesen davor. Vor einer
Weile das Microsoft Zertifikat jetzt nicht mehr weiter verfolgt. Aber ob die alle eingestellt
haben keine Ahnung. Kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Die ganze Microsoft Zertifizierung ist so ein
selbstversorgendes Ökosystem. Auch die ganzen Azure Zertifizierungen das wollen ja. Cloud
Zertifizierungen sind tatsächlich was, was aktuell relativ angesagt ist. Weil halt sehr
viele Leute weil das neu ist und sehr viele Leute sagen ich bin ein krasse Cloud Experte
aber keinen blassen Schimmer. Und man muss halt auch sagen dass sowohl die Bedienung von
Azure von AWS als auch von ich kann mir immer nicht merken wie das Google Ding heißt. Google
Clouds. GCS wie heißt das Google Ding? Die Google Cloud. Ich kann mir den Namen von der
Google Cloud nicht merken. Die haben alle irgendwelche Zertifizierungen die zumindest sagen. GCP?
Ich weiß nicht genau. Die haben alle irgendwelche. Ohje Corona am Start wieder. Die haben alle
irgendwelche. Nicht Google Drive ich meine die Google Cloud Plattform. Wo man Container
Kubernetes Schiss machen kann drinne. Die haben alle irgendwelche Zertifizierungen und die
sind auch schon zumindest insofern sinnvoll dass man sehen kann derjenige weiß wie man
den Kram bedienen kann. Und sowohl Google Cloud als auch AWS. Also ich hab bisher in
AWS hab ich ehrlich gesagt noch nie groß was gemacht. Ich hab nur was bisher in Google
Cloud und mit Azure gemacht. Und die Bedienung die ist bei allen so abartig durch die Brust
ins Auge und kompliziert dass es tatsächlich sinnvoll ist da eine Zertifizierung sich
zeigen zu lassen wenn einer sagt er kennt sich damit aus. Dann weiß er zumindest er
weiß was er macht. Du bist in der Suppe geleakt ich weiß. Ja ideal was meinst du noch mal
für eine Seite die ich zeigen soll? Ich hab die voll verpeilt. Was denkst du zu Lpick?
Hatten wir auch? Lpick. Ich hab ehrlich gesagt noch nicht einen gesehen der einen Lpick hatte
und deswegen genommen wurde. Das ist nicht so verbreitet. Aber das ist nur meine Meinung
also das bedeutet gar nichts. Das Endzone Gamestar Video das können wir tatsächlich
gucken. Achso. Volumen Master. Prom. Doch das gibt's noch das hab ich erst letztens
installiert. Ja. Volumen Master. Da ist es. Die PETA. Ich wusste gar nicht dass die PETA
jetzt auch Browserplugins machen. Cuts FPS approved. Das Gamestar Video. Ja das können
wir uns angucken. Irgendwas im Auge. Man sagt ja immer wenn man was im Auge hat so reiben
bringt nix man muss ja eigentlich von aus nach innen aber ich mach das nicht. Ich schreib
einfach wild am Auge rum dass es irgendwann weg ist. Also das ist nicht sonderlich optimal
ich weiß. RIP Auge. Alter. Das ist jetzt mal raus. Achso das sind Chromeplugins. Aber
es gibt sowas hundertprozentig auf Firefox. Tausend tausendprozentig. Ignorieren und drei
Stunden leiden ist excellent advice. Huge. Der Kommentator ist am Start. Moin. Pepoclap.
Oh das Emote heißt wirklich Pepoclap. Ich hab das jetzt einfach nur so bauchgefühlmäßig
gesagt und kenne mittlerweile viel zu viele Emotes. Alter kann immer das Zeug aus dem
Auge jetzt rausgehen ey. Kommt das überhaupt her? Ich sitz vor dem Rechner und guck grad
auf den Monitor. Ich kann überhaupt nichts ins Auge kriegen. Nimm mal Fenster auf nix.
Ja gucken wir. Haben wir das schon aufgemacht? Ja. Dazu fällt mir nur das hier ein. Das
ist eh ein sehr underusedes Emote muss ich sagen. Finde ich fast die beste MonkaS Variante
aber kaum einer benutzt MonkaS. MonkaGiga ist auch okay wobei ich MonkaS eigentlich
am besten finde. So hatten wir. Du hast den Internetführerschein. Excellent. Den haben
nur ganz wenige. Die wollten nen LPG haben okay. Nicht schlecht. Ist die einzigen die
ich bisher gehört hab gesehen hab was auch immer Berichte gesehen hab die nen LPG haben
wollten. Nice. So mit was fangen wir heute denn an Leute? Mit was fangen wir dann an?
Wir haben sehr viel Zeug zur Auswahl. Battlefield 5 ist cancelled. Das müssen wir uns die Nachricht
müssen wir uns tatsächlich mal durchlesen. Weil ich hab das auch nur jetzt in ein paar
Videos gesehen. Battlefield 5 steht kurz nach dem Ende. Spieler fassungslos. Und was ist
die? Der Standard.de. Ist das nicht irgendeine österreichische News Seite? Bisschen leicht
Clickbait Überschrifter. Ich mein mtf. Spieler fassungslos. Battlefield steht nach kurzer
Zeit vor dem Ende. GameStar hat es. Gucken wir mal bei der GameStar. Ich bin jemand der
sagt Gott sei dank ist Battlefield 5 am Ende. Da kommt vielleicht irgendwann mal ein gescheites
Battlefield. Battlefield. Gibt's nicht. Haben die hier geschrieben dass das eingestellt
wurde? Das Ende von Battlefield 5 ist traurig. Kommt aber nicht unerwartet. Das Spiel war
halt einfach von Anfang an so viel gefailt. Das geht auf keine. Wie heißt das? Es geht
auf keine Haut. Es geht auf keine Kuhhaut. Genau. Was eigentlich total beknackter Spruch
ist. Was kann die Kuh dafür? Wie benutzt du deinen Manjaro auf der Arbeit? Nativ oder
auch in Armee? Richtig installiert auf Notebook. Ich entdocke das einfach nicht. Ich verwende
das Notebook eigentlich fast nur stationär. Mit Kapitel 6 endet der Content Support für
Battlefield 5. Weiß jemand von euch wie der ursprüngliche Plan war? Der ursprüngliche
Plan war doch dass man 2021 erst anfangen will überhaupt mit einem neuen Battlefield
oder sowas. Ich weiß auch gar nicht wieviel ursprünglich kommen sollte. Battlefield 5
Roadmap. Schauen wir mal was da ursprünglich gedacht war. Roadmap. New Map. Moment, in
welchem Jahr sind wir? 2019 ist das. Chapter 5. Na gut, sie haben es ja auch nur bis Chapter
5 angekündigt. Und das erste halbe Jahr 2020 ist schon um. Die wollten bestimmt 10 Kapitel
machen. Naja, was auch immer. Mal gucken was die GameStar als größte Fails von Battlefield
5 sieht. Also ich kann wenig, also rein aus Spielersicht wenig Gutes, noch wenig großartig
Schlechtes über das Game sagen. Außer dass es mich nicht so gecatcht hat richtig. Ich
habe die Alpha gespielt, da bin ich mit der Zeit dann immer besser reingekommen. Haben
wir ja schon relativ oft zu Gamma gestreamt. Lief eigentlich auch ganz gut. Dann irgendwie
hat mir aber das ganze drum herum und auch vor allem Navig als Map überhaupt nicht
gefallen. Auch diese komischen Killstreak Raketen da waren nicht irgendwie so meins und
drum herum hat es mir auch nicht so zugesagt. Beim Release habe ich mir trotzdem gekauft
im Vergleich zu Battlefield 1. Fand es gar nicht so schlecht, auch wenn mir halt Rush
echt gefehlt hat. Ich weiß da gab es ganz gute Ersatz. Also eine Sache die mir persönlich
und das habe ich in meinem Review Video auch gesagt, dass das nichts ist was das Spiel
an sich schlecht macht, sondern nur so eine persönliche Sache von mir ist, die mir nicht
gefallen hat. Eine ganz kleine Sache, aber die mir richtig groß im Kopf geblieben ist
in Battlefield 5, neben anderen Sachen wie die Waffenentwicklung und sonst was. Aber
eine Sache die mir echt im Kopf geblieben ist, nicht dass sie weibliche Soldaten hatten
oder sowas. Das war mir eigentlich vollkommen egal, sondern dass die weiblichen Soldaten
so rumgeschrien haben. Und ich mag Leute nicht die rumschreien. Es ist jetzt egal ob
Frauen oder Männer, aber Frauen die mit hoher Stimme schreien ist dann nochmal besonders
nervig finde ich. Und das dann im Spiel, das brauche ich nicht. Und ich weiß auch nicht
was mit den Sound Leuten los war. Die Battlefield Soldaten die machen wenn sie erschossen werden
machen irgendwie so was. Und die Mädels in Battlefield waren übelst nervig. Ist auch
nicht warum. Das ist eine Sache die nur auf Geeks gegangen ist. Und ansonsten gab es auch
ein paar andere Sachen. Die Waffenentwicklung fand ich ein bisschen fragwürdig. Mir hat
wie gesagt der Beta die Maps auch überhaupt nicht gefallen, mir hat Rush gefehlt. Aber
ansonsten kann ich weder großartig Gutes noch Schlechtes über das Game sagen. Ich habe
es kaum gespielt. Das hat mich halt nicht so wirklich gecatcht. Also der Reveal Trailer
war auf jeden Fall ein richtiger Fail. Der war so für ein Arsch der Reveal Trailer.
Vor allem haben die sich selbst ins eigene Fleisch geschnitten. Die haben das so verkackt
den Reveal Trailer. Die haben nämlich, vielleicht könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern. Die Maps
finde ich auch nicht gut die ich bisher gesehen habe. Also die haben nämlich falls ihr euch
noch dran erinnern könnt. Die sind total abgegangen auf wie authentisch und quasi wie
erzählen die Storys der unerzählten Geschichten so nach dem Motto aus dem Battlefield. Das
ist das authentischste und das immersivste und das überhaupt genialste World War 2 Game
aller Zeiten. Das heißt du hast jetzt eigentlich erwartet, dass du irgendwie einen ziemlich
nah an der Realität befindlichen, recht atmosphärischen, vielleicht auch brutalen und erwachsenen
Trailer, einfach einen atmosphärischen Trailer siehst, wo du sagst fuck ich hoffe ich komme
nie in so eine Situation so nach dem Motto. So hast du gedacht nach der Ankündigung und
dann kommt ein Trailer, wo Panzer durch Häuser fahren, Leute mit schottischer Kriegsbemalung
am Start sind, schwarze Soldaten mit Katana auf dem Rücken und eine Frau mit krallen
Hand. Und da haben alle schon nach Moment, ihr habt euch jetzt 45 Minuten da irgendwie
einen runtergeholt drauf, wie authentisch immersiv und überhaupt toll, da kommt sowas,
da waren alle echt verwirrt als sie den Trailer gesehen haben. Das war auch ein wahnsinniger
Trailer. Und der nächste Fail war, der eigentlich schon größere Fail, den Rest hätte man noch
ändern können und angeblich haben sie auch einige Sachen daraus entfernt. Ich meine
im fertigen Spiel gibt es ja anscheinend keine Clown Hunt mehr und sowas. Der größte Fail
danach war eigentlich der, was der Dice Chef, der gesagt hat, er will seiner Tochter nicht
erklären müssen, warum es in dem Spiel keine weiblichen Soldaten gibt und mit seinen Storys
sind sie ja quasi auf der richtigen Seite der Geschichte und wer es nicht mag, der soll
es nicht bestellen bzw. nicht kaufen. Und das war der Punkt wo es nach unten ging, weil
einmal haben die Leute das Richtige gemacht. Anscheinend brauchen die erst die Genehmigung
vom Dice Chef, sie haben es nicht gekauft. Sie haben es vor allem nicht vorbestellt und
die Vorbestellerzahlen von Battlefield 5 waren unglaublich scheiße. Daraufhin haben sie
dann ein bisschen zurückgerudert, der Dicetyp ist ja mittlerweile weg, aber mehr verkacken
kann man es nicht. Ich bin immer noch der Meinung, sie hätten das Spiel so machen sollen,
wie sie ursprünglich wollten, also mit Soldaten, mit Katana, mit Soldaten, mit Clown in der
Hand. Ich bin da mal, sie hätten das Spiel genauso machen sollen, wie es ihnen ursprünglich
vorgeschwebt ist. Allerdings, sie hätten es nicht verkaufen sollen als zweite Weltkriegs
Simulation, sondern sie hätten es verkaufen sollen als komplett neuer Ansatz, was diese
Epoche angeht, nämlich indem sie sich an nichts halten, was wirklich gewesen ist, sondern
quasi den Ablauf, wie er in echt war, als grobes Vorbild nehmen und so ein alternatives
Realitätsszenario machen. Da hätte man richtig geile Storys machen können für den Singleplayer,
ohne sich so den Anschein geben zu müssen, es wäre realitätsbasiert und man hätte
den größten Schwachsinn in den Multiplayer bauen können, es hätte keinen gejuckt. Die
hätten das Spiel einfach so machen sollen, wie sie ursprünglich vorhatten, plus dass
sie das Szenario halt als nicht hyperrealistische zweite Weltkriegsatmosphäre und Simulation
verkaufen. Ja, genau, das hier war es. Kriegsbemalung, ohne Clown in der Hand, der Soldat mit dem
Katana ist nicht am Start. Habes, habes verkackt. Zu dem Versprechen, ein takterischeres Battlefield
für Hardcore-Fans abzuliefern, schien die Szene jedenfalls so gar nicht... Das stimmt,
das stimmt. Das Spiel ist auch kein taktisches Battlefield für Hardcore-Fans, das ist halt
irgendwas zusammengewurstet, das von Leuten, die nicht mehr wissen, wie man ein scheiß
Battlefield macht. Moin, kennt einer von euch das Problem, dass ihr den Prime-Sub nicht
vergeben könnt? Ich hatte mal das Problem, da musste ich mich ausloggen, wieder einloggen,
dann hat es funktioniert, aber ansonsten hatte ich da noch keine Probleme, nee. Oder war
das ein... Oder war das ein Gebate, das alle mal ausprobieren, ob sie nicht ihren Prime-Sub
noch vergeben können. Dann wär das aber ein ziemlich guter Gebate gewesen, wenn's
einer war. Also ich... Und diese ganze Service-Game-Ausrichtung von Battlefield 5 hab ich ja gar keine Probleme
mit. Ich hätte mir ja schon für Battlefield 4 damals gewünscht, oder für Battlefield
3, die hätten das 4 Jahre supportet, mit neuem Content. Gerade Battlefield 3. Funkwehr abonniert
Twitch Prime, Dankeschön, huge Sub. Excellent Sub. Aber halt bei einem Game, was ich grundsätzlich
geil fände, und das war halt Battlefield 5 vielleicht. Progression war für'n Arsch,
das stimmt. Das liegt aber auch mit daran, wenn das Game an sich den Spielern nicht reicht,
dann schreien sie nach mehr Unlocks und Progression. Es gab mal ne Zeit, da hat das Gameplay alleine
gereicht. Das muss nicht unbedingt sein. Ich find, Bad Company 2 hat's ganz schön gemacht,
auch Battlefield 3. Das hat richtig lange gedauert, bis du da auf Max-Rank warst. Da
hast du noch die ganzen Colonel-Level in Battlefield 3 gehabt. Das war ganz gut. Ich finde, es
braucht gar nicht riesige Sachen, sondern es ist einfach nur schön, wenn man sieht,
jeder mag das, wenn irgendwelche Zahlen hochgehen. Richtig stonksmäßig. Deswegen. Und wenn
man irgendwann mal Colonel 100 ist, ist es doch richtig nice. Vorallem, wenn es auch
ein Achievement ist und nicht jeder hat's. Das Hin und Her mit dem Gunplay. Oh ja, das
hab ich gar nicht mehr mitgekriegt. Da hab ich ja gar nicht mehr gespielt, großartig.
Aber das war ne Riesendiskussion. Da haben sie es voll verschissen. Der mangelnde Content-Nachschub
und das lustigerweise bei nem Game, das von Anfang an angekündigt war als Service-Game.
Das ist eigentlich lächerlich, ne? Dass man gerade bei nem Game, was als Langzeit mit
regelmäßigem Content angelegt ist, der Content nicht nachkommt. Firestorm war, glaube ich,
ziemlich verschwendete Entwicklerzeit. Keine Sau spielt mehr Firestorm. Wisst ihr überhaupt
noch was Firestorm ist? Ist das Royal Firestorm oder so? Firestorm. Fire. Firestorm. Wie schreibt
man das überhaupt? Firestorm. Spielt das überhaupt jemand? Exzellent. Oh. Ne. Past Videos. Doch
hier, guck mal. Hier spielen welche Battlefield? Mit 24, 57, 9 und 129 Viewer. Huge. Massive.
Viewer. Das ist rausgekommen, ja? So. Angeblich, ja, das hab ich auch gelesen, dass ergeblich
gar nicht schlecht war. Das war auch, das war auch Fail. Es gab nen neuen Singleplayer.
Ach, stimmt, es gab nen neuen Singleplayer. Singleplayer hab ich mal, hab ich mal versucht,
hab ich 5 Minuten gespielt, hab ich keinen Bock mehr. Ja. Ja, also, da bin ich echt mal
gespannt. Mal gucken, was er hier dazu sagt. Mal gucken, was er hier dazu sagt, zu Battlefield
Content eingestellt. Ähm, ich hoffe ja immer noch drauf, dass irgendwann mal, oder hoffentlich
vielleicht sogar als nächstes, aber ich glaub ja nicht dran, wenn Bad Company 3 kommt, was
von Leuten gemacht wird, die wissen, was ein gutes Bad Company ausmacht. Aber die Hoffnung
hab ich eigentlich fast schon aufgegeben. Boah, da redet er wieder wahnsinnig geschwind.
Excellent. Auf 1,25 geht das doch relativ gut, oder? Wir müssen, wisst ihr was, bevor
wir uns das Video angucken, schauen wir uns einfach mal den offiziellen Future of Battlefield.
Wir gucken uns einfach mal den offiziellen Post an. Wie heißt der Typ, Ryan? Ryan, irgendwas.
Hier, da. Also. Hallo. Ähm, gibt's das, gibt's das auch, ich guck mir mal ganz gern an,
wie sie die Dinger übersetzen. Ah, ne, gibt's nicht. Also. Mal den Dark Reader aus. Ah.
Jäh. Das ist mir zu grell. Ah, jetzt. Exos besser. Moin, Querdos. Ah, bla, bla, bla, bla.
Wären die Spiele ordentlich modbar, dann würde das auch wunderbar funktionieren. What's
coming after Battlefield Chapter 6? Ok. Inter-Gel wraps up. 29. April. One more, also ein weiteres
Update im Sommer. Äh, neue Waffen Game Tricks. Im Juni. Warte mal, Juni? Juli? Juni, ne? Ähm,
work from home. Bla, bla, bla, bla. Bla, bla, bla. New Update im Sommer. Weekly Rewards juckt mich nicht. Event und Activities,
es braucht auch kein Mensch. Community Games Update. Ok. Ja, lass die Leute die Arbeit machen,
die können's wahrscheinlich mittlerweile eh besser. As the Battle Rage is on. Die schreiben
die immer so, wie nennt man das? Diese Texte sind immer so gefüllt mit so schönen Zwischendingern.
Anstatt einfach nur einen Satz zu schreiben, so Battlefield 5 dead. Lul. Continue to work. Anti-Cheat, ok.
Weiß ich nicht, wie gut das funktioniert in Battlefield 4. Wie ist das Anti-Cheat so in
Battlefield 4? Äh, Battlefield 5? Ach, die Benahmung von Battlefield. Eine Fresse. Battlefield 5 mein ich nicht
Battlefield 4. Vergesst, was ich gesagt hab. Wie ist das Anti-Cheat so? Ähm. 20th Summer. Das war's?
Das ist ja geil. Das ist ja, das ist wieder so richtig, wenn man das liest, ne, wirkt das Ganze
eigentlich positiv. So nach dem Motto, oh cool, der kündigt ein neues Update an. Aber was er in
Wirklichkeit ankündigt ist, was man da rauslesen muss eigentlich, ähm, dass er nichts Weiteres
ankündigt, ist eigentlich die Sache, die darauf hindeute, dass das Ganze eingestellt wird. Ah ja,
listen to community feedback. Da seid ihr a huge brain drin. Ah, es gibt keine comments. Wird mich
auch wundern bei meinen comments. Ok, was sagt reddit? Reddit sagt, deleted. Lul. Da sind sie immer schnell
dabei. Ach hier, es gibt nen neuen Chats. Ja, stimmt. Stimmt, eigentlich gibt es in Battlefield
wirklich nix, wo man, was man so mit Zweiten Weltkrieg Shooter in Verbindung bringt. Kein
DJ, keine Ostfront, kein Berlin, ja. Das stimmt schon, ja. Na gut, ganz ehrlich, mich freut sogar
ein bisschen, ähm, weil wir dann jetzt vielleicht die Chance haben, ein ordentliches Battlefield mal
wieder zu bekommen. Weil das sollte ja DICE gezeigt haben, die Leute haben keinen Bock auf den Scheiß.
Aber ich glaube, die haben einfach keine Leute mehr, die ordentliches Battlefield machen können.
Ist vorbei. Meine persönliche Hoffnung ist ja immer noch auf ein neues Battle, äh, nicht Battle Royale,
was sag ich denn da? Fuck, ne? Neues Bad Company. So, also, was gucken wir jetzt als Nächstes?
Burger gucken wir nicht. Wir gucken jetzt, oh, hands-on neues Windows 10 Update. Stimmt, es kam
ja, es kam ja ein neues Windows 10 Update raus. Schauen wir uns mal an, was es für
bahnbrechende Farbschemaänderungen am Windows Calculator wieder gibt. Viel mehr kann es ja nicht sein.
Dicht ist richtig. Es gibt jetzt Desktop Sticky Notizen. Was, was es quasi schon seit 20 Jahren,
30 Jahren gibt. Okay. Oder gibt's das schon? Oder gibt's das schon? Ich verwende das nicht.
Sticky Notes, ah ne, das gibt's schon. Das ist gar nichts Neues. Vergiss, was ich gesagt hab. Ist
gar nichts Neues. Ist alles Zeug, ja. Zeig's mal her. Also ich tippe drauf, ich predikte mal. Ich
predikte mal Änderungen in der neuen Windows 10 Version. Also ich predikte, dass das Taschenrechner
Farbschema sich ändert. Dass irgendwelche Buttons im Startmenü umsortiert wurden. Dass die Suche
angeblich jetzt endlich funktioniert. Wo man natürlich nicht sagt, die Suche funktioniert
endlich, sondern sagt, die Suche wurde verbessert und ist jetzt so gut wie nie. Aber im Prinzip
funktioniert die Windows Suche ja nicht richtig. Dass der Explorer, das könnte nämlich endlich mal kommen, dass der Explorer, ach der hat schon Ribbons.
Okay, ich hab nix gesagt. Der Explorer hat Ribbons. Ich guck da so selten rein. Okay, der Explorer hat schon Ribbons.
Was könnte als nächstes kommen? Dass man noch ein paar alte Menüs geupgraded hat von Windows XP auf
das neue Design. Und ja, was könnte Microsoft denn Neues machen? Irgendwelche, irgendwelchen Tablet- und
Stiftsupport oder Gedöns, was keiner braucht. Ja, mal gucken. Ich kann mir nichts Großartiges vorstellen,
bahnbrechendes. Ah ja, doch, ich weiß was. Eins fällt mir noch ein. Sie haben Cortana mal wieder umgebaut und die
funktioniert jetzt wieder komplett anders. Der hat auch schon seinen Mauszeiger auf Cortana. Sie haben
Cortana wieder mal umgebaut, weil die bauen ja fast jedes Windows Update Cortana um. Das haben sie
bestimmt wieder gemacht. In a previous release of Windows 10, Microsoft separated Cortana from the Windows Search Bar.
Ich sag's euch. Ich wusste es, ich wusste es. Und ihr habt es gesehen, ich hab das gesagt bevor ich es gehört habe.
Ich wusste es. Cortana kommt wieder irgendwie, bauen die wieder irgendwas um. So that they could focus on improving the Windows
Search Experience. Als hätt ich es gewusst. Cortana und Windows Suche. On the other hand was severely neglected
and lost much of her previous functionality. However Windows 10 version 2004 is bringing much of that functionality back.
Microsoft is rebranding Cortana to a quote personal productivity assistant. Oh Gott, geht die Schwätze.
Microsoft 365 Workflows. Microsoft 365 ist übrigens Office 365, weil die Microsoft hat sich bei ihrer Big Brain
Benamung. Also Microsoft, wir hatten es ja gestern von.NET 5, was jetzt eigentlich.NET Core 4, also was auch immer.
Xbox Scarlett ist ja Xbox XS1, was auch immer. Dass Microsoft es mit Benamung nicht sonderlich hat, haben wir ja
schon festgestellt. Und ähm. 65 Workflows. Deswegen haben sie auch Office unbenannt. Jetzt wo sich die
Leute merken konnten. Office 365. Wird das Ding unbenannt in Microsoft 365. Jetzt gerade wo sich die Leute sich das
merken können. Oh das heißt auch, das heißt auch man kann es komplett deinstallieren. Jo, ist absolut null.
Benutzt, ernst gemeinte Frage Chat. Benutzt ihr Cortana? Wir machen jetzt mal eine Umfrage. Da bin ich jetzt mal
gespannt. Straw Pool. Also wir machen jetzt mal eine Umfrage. Was benutzt ihr? Welchen Assistant benutzt ihr?
Also was haben wir da einmal. Cortana. Google. Ich glaube das Ding heißt einfach nur Google Assistant. Siri. Was haben wir
noch? Was gibt es noch? Also verbreitetes. Was gibt es noch? Alexa. Google Ads. Bixby kenne ich überhaupt. Was ist
was ist Bixby? Ok. Ich wusste gar nicht, dass es existiert. Aber ich nehme es damit rein. Ok. Also allow multiple
Answers. IP Checking. Was auch immer. Create. Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt Leute. Bin ich mal gespannt ob das überhaupt. Ah gar kein. Ja.
Ja wartet mal Leute. Ich mach das neu. Ich hab's verkackt. Ich mach das neu. Ich mach das neu. Ihr müsst nicht abstimmen.
Ich mach das neu. Also Cortana. Google Assistant. Alexa. Was war das? Siri. Oder wie ist das andere? Bixby? Bixby hab ich noch nie gehört.
Keinen. Ok. Allow multiple Answers. Create. Jetzt haben wir es Leute. Jetzt haben wir es. Hier. Das ist der richtige. Also Results. Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
ob den Kram jemand benutzt. Boah der Chat. Keinen. Ok. Oh wir haben einen Cortana Benutzer. Out sich der Cortana Benutzer auch im Chat.
Zwei Cortana Benutzer. Ok. Das hab ich so erwartet, dass das ungefähr gleich groß ist. Ich hätte jetzt persönlich, persönlich hätte ich
gedacht, dass Alexa vorne ist. Weil es ja nicht an irgendwelche Smartphone Geschichten oder sonst wie gebunden ist. Ich weiß Google Assistant
auch nicht. Aber Alexa gibt es ja zig weitere Produkte dazu. Ok. Nice. Ja schön, dass so viele mitgemacht haben. Ich mein guck mal.
142 Votes von 250 Zuschauern. Das ist ziemlich, ziemlich massive. Also was man daran sich schön erkennen kann. Die meisten Leute verwenden
keinen Voice Assistant. Da gehöre ich auch dazu. Ich verwende keinen Voice Assistant. Bixby verwenden auch kaum einer. Ich hab's noch nie gehört.
Ich wusste bis eben gar nicht, dass es existiert. Ich hab erwartet, dass die ungefähr gleich auf sind. Wobei ich persönlich gedacht
hab, dass Alexa vorne liegt. So ein paar Prozent oder so. Weil es halt auch zusätzliche Alexa Geräte gibt. Also du hast diese ganzen
Echo Dinger und sonst was. Ich hab eigentlich gedacht, dass Alexa ein bisschen vorne liegt. Aber ok. Es ist ziemlich genau. Was ja auch Sinn
ergibt. Apple, Google verteilt sich so. Verbreitung ist hier mehr. Aber die Apple Fans finden alles, was Apple macht, geil.
Das gleicht sich ein bisschen aus. Also anteilmäßig denke ich mal, dass mehr Leute Siri verwenden, die Apple haben als Google Assistant
die Google Produkte verwenden. Aber das wundert mich, dass Alexa nicht ein bisschen weiter vorne liegt und Cortana verwendet auch so gut wie keiner.
Also Bixby und Cortana ist beides nicht so beliebt. Ich hab mal ein bisschen rumprobiert auf meinem Shield TV. Sowohl mit Alexa.
Da gab es ja eine zusätzliche Alexa App, die man installieren konnte. Über den Custom App Store und mit Google Assistant.
Ich hab festgestellt, es bringt absolut gar nichts, weil die Integration massiv suckt. Was richtig cool gewesen wäre,
das alte Shield TV hatte eine Fernbedienung dabei. Da musstest du den Knopf drücken. Nur dann hat sich das Mikro eingeschaltet.
Das war schon mal gut. Was richtig cool wäre, wenn du hättest sagen können, 20.15 Uhr Tagesschau aufnehmen oder sowas.
Nicht, dass ich Tagesschau aufnehmen will, aber so als Beispiel. Das wäre eigentlich ganz cool gewesen, aber nicht funktionieren.
Deswegen. Und seitdem hab ich mich damit nie wieder beschäftigt. Und ansonsten bin ich ja auch der Meinung, so schnell wie ich den Kram tippe
und so schnell wie ich quasi weiß, was ich tippen will und machen will, ist kein Voice Assistant.
Also so schnell ich mein Notizprogramm aufgemacht hab und was reingeschrieben hab und gesavet hab, bis ich dann gesagt hab, Alexa Style,
irgendwie Alexa, sag Notizprogramm, öffne Notiz, füge Notiz hinzu, ich will jetzt öfter streamen, Notiz Ende.
Immer. Ja, da hab ich das schon 5 Mal selbst gemacht. Aber interessant, das Ergebnis speise ich mir mal.
Das kann ich vielleicht mal für ein Video brauchen. Kann man Votes eigentlich closen, dass jetzt nicht irgendjemand
krasse Troll-Votes macht danach? Nee, geht nicht.
Screenshot. Ne, Screenshot ist outdated, overrated, gebated, Screenshot machen wir nicht.
Okay, weiter gucken, was für Windows Funktionen es gibt. Screenshot. Nee, nee, nee. So, old school Sachen machen wir gar nicht.
Mein Freund, wo sind wir stehen geblieben? Ach, es schreibt Cortana.
Leute, ich hab euch gesagt, Cortana und Windows Suche und zack, was kommt als erstes Cortana und Windows Suche?
Gibt's das nicht jetzt schon? Das gibt's doch jetzt schon, oder? Wo ist überhaupt meine Suchleiste?
Wo, Leute, wo ist meine Suchleiste? Ist die weg? Wo ist die hin? Ist die nicht immer da normalerweise?
Nee, nur ein Monitor. Search. Hab ich Search ausgeblendet? Search. Ah, Search-Icon. Okay, nice. Guck, das ist doch jetzt schon da.
Das ist doch gar nichts Neues. Okay, Wetter. In Bruchkörbe? Nee, nicht so ganz. Ist zwar nicht weit weg, aber nicht so ganz.
Ähm, 15 Grad. Excellent.
Was hast du für eine Windows Version? Ähm, wo sieht man das?
CMD? WinFair oder so? Nee, äh. Moment, warum hab ich hier immer noch das Windows 98 ISO? WinFair? 1903 hab ich.
Ich bin richtig outdated. Ich bin ein Jahr hinten dran mit Updates, Leute. Monkeys.
Ich muss mal wieder updaten, ne?
Was?
Ah! Okay, das ist doch, ist doch ganz nett. Werd ich wahrscheinlich nie verwenden, aber ist doch ganz nett.
Erstmal der Minecraft-Turm hier. Habt ihr gesehen, was hat er da in der Startleiste drin? Instagram-Template und Minecraft. Excellent.
Oh!
Ich hab im Vorfeld auch gesagt, ich erwarte, dass das Calculator Farbschema sich ändert.
Ich, Leute, ich schwöre euch, ich hab das Video vorher nicht geguckt.
Ich hatte keine Ahnung. Das war einfach random, was ich erzählt hab und irgendwie stimmt das alles.
Ups, irgendwie stimmt das alles.
Ja, das hab ich schon immer gebraucht.
Always on top Calculator, den hab ich schon immer gebraucht.
Ja, das wär ja auch nicht auszudenken, wenn Microsoft eine neue Sache ankündigt und dann auf einen Schlag alle Sachen aktualisiert werden.
Stimmt, das Farbschema ist nicht anders, tatsächlich ist es der Calculator der on top state.
Ja, das stimmt, da hatte ich nicht recht, das ist richtig.
Exposed.
Aber das ist von Microsoft typisch, so nach dem Motto, wir haben eine neue Icon-Richtlinie.
Ja, wie? Wir sollen alle unsere eigenen Icons aktualisieren.
Nee, nee, nee, das machen wir nicht. Das machen wir vielleicht über die nächsten 5 Jahre in Updates.
Wow, das haben wir schon mal in einem Video gesehen, dass der Task Manager das jetzt kann.
Da haben wir uns damals schon drüber kaputt gelacht.
Okay, warum nicht?
Ich meine, brauchen wir das echt? Ich meine, jeder Grafiktreiber hat so ein Kram dabei.
Aber warum nicht? Ja, dann ist es eine einheitliche Oberfläche.
Mich würde interessieren, sind die auch, wie sieht es da mit der Performance aus, das würde mich interessieren.
Weil ich weiß, dass die ganze Shadowplay-Geschichte und Overlays, das bezieht im Endeffekt nichts.
So, wie es da aussieht, weiß ich nicht.
Klar hat Nvidia eine Overlay für FPS. Ach so, RAM-Usage. Das stimmt, das stimmt.
Aber was interessiert mich RAM-Usage? FPS-Overlay, natürlich ein Nvidia-FPS-Overlay.
Das ist doch das Einzige, was sie haben. Ja, da.
Da. Kannste einblenden lassen. FPS-Counter.
Alt-Z. Big Brain Shortcut.
Und das ist Emoji, ne? Macht's doch jetzt schon. Macht's doch jetzt schon.
Muss man dafür GeForce Experience installieren? Ja, klar.
Ach stimmt, der Kram ist jetzt neu. Ja, das hab ich auch schon mal gelesen.
Okay, wer was braucht?
Nur mit dem Unterschied, dass die Netzwerk-Settings in dem neuen Settings-Menü immer noch wahnsinnig scheiße sind.
Ich hab's mal versucht, ihr guckt mal. Also, nur mal zum Vergleich.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie komm ich denn da überhaupt jetzt hin.
Hier. So. Mal angenommen, ich will jetzt rauskriegen, wie ist denn meine Mac-Adresse.
Ethernet. Connected. Zwei. Aha.
Immerhin. Da steht sie. Edit. Okay, man kann mittlerweile DNS und alles ändern.
Wie mach ich das Interface an und aus? Wie mach ich das Interface an und aus?
Also, mal angenommen, ich will jetzt das Interface ausschalten, wie mach ich das?
Geht nicht, oder? Change adapter options?
Ah, das ist das alte. Ja klar, dass es über das alte Menü geht, weiß ich.
Dass es über das alte Menü geht mit Disable, das weiß ich. Aber über das neue?
Da ist nur die Hälfte wieder drin, ich weiß nicht, was für ein Microsoft los.
Ja, ja. Auch diese ganzen Dinger, die man so gut wie nie braucht, aber man kann einfach.
Ich weiß auch nicht, warum sie das unbedingt. Und ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ja.
So alt backen, dass manchmal wirkt, geht überhaupt OBS noch, ja.
So alt backen, dass manchmal wirkt, diese Menüs hier, ich finde die eigentlich ganz schick.
Die XP Style Menüs, ich finde die eigentlich ganz schick. Die haben die Zeit ganz gut überstanden.
Da gibt es auch nichts großartiges dagegen zu sagen. Das sind relativ hübsche Icons.
Du erkennst gleich, ob der Kram an und aus ist. Das hier sieht auch halbwegs okay aus.
Also ich verstehe die Existenzberechtigung dieser neuen Settings Menüs ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Man hätte hier sicherlich die Sachen ein bisschen aufgeräumter machen können, ein bisschen logischer, ein bisschen schöner machen können.
Keine Frage. Aber wozu braucht man überhaupt das neue Settings Menü?
Habe ich seit Anfang an nicht verstanden. Wegen Tablet-Freundlichkeit.
Dann sollte man das konsequent machen. Und das ist etwas, was Microsoft nicht kann.
Wenn man sagt, ja, ist Tablet-Freundlichkeit, das ist natürlich Tablet-mäßig scheiße zu bedienen, das geht nicht.
Wenn man sagt, ja, wir wollen das Tablet-freundlich machen und wir können das alte nicht Tablet-freundlich umbauen.
Wir machen was Neues. Dann konsequent. Man muss sich mal vorstellen, die brauchen jetzt...
Wann kam Windows 10 raus? 2015 oder so? Oder 2017? Wann war Windows 10 Release?
15. Die machen jetzt 5 Jahre an diesem Settings Menü rum und die Optionen, die halt nur manchmal wichtig sind, aber dafür dann ziemlich wichtig,
oder auch viele andere Optionen haben es da immer noch nicht reingeschafft. Seit 5 Jahren.
Also sowas halbherziges habe ich selten gesehen.
Das weiß ich auch nicht, was da mit Microsoft los ist.
Das ist ganz cool, dass man jetzt einzelne Anwendungen anscheinend limitieren kann. Okay, nice.
Das ist tatsächlich ganz gut.
Ich meine, aber jetzt mal ernsthaft, das ist doch kein schönes Menü. Das ist doch ernsthaft kein schönes Menü.
Das sieht aus wie eine HTML-Form ohne jegliches Styling. Das sieht hässlich wie die Nacht aus.
Einfach untereinander Form-Dinger geschrieben. Das sieht nicht gut aus. Und übersichtlich schon mal gar nicht.
Das ist wirklich eine HTML-Form, wo dann vielleicht jemand noch so pro war und hat gesagt, Body, Background, Color, Black. Fertig.
Fertig.
Und was da fehlt, oh, ich wollte gerade sagen, was da fehlt sind Zahlen, aber wenigstens kommt die Zahl beim Overlay.
Wo kann man die Mausbeschleunigung ausschalten?
Wo ist Mausbeschleunigung? Wie kann man die Mausbeschleunigung ausschalten?
Das muss ich jetzt mal kurz gucken. Maus.
Das geht nur über das alte Mausmenü. Moment, wo ist es denn?
Das da. Enhanced Pointer Position ist Mausbeschleunigung, oder?
Das ist doch lächerlich. Das ist doch ein Witz.
Mausbeschleunigung ist das erste, was man als Gamer braucht, was man ausschaltet.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, nichts halbes und nichts ganzes, aber das ist eher ein Viertel und nichts ganzes.
Das habe ich schon immer gebraucht, so ein Ding.
Ich meine, das ist ja alles ganz nett. Das ist ja alles ganz nett.
Es ist ja auch okay, dass das da ist, aber wie wäre es denn erstmal, die Sachen, die man schon vor 5 Jahren angefangen hat, mal ordentlich fertig zu machen?
Endlich.
Na, endlich.
Wie wäre es mit ganz normalem, ich gebe ein Passwort einem Login und dann geht mir Windows nicht mehr auf den Sack?
Endlich.
Will ich nicht! Will ich nicht!
Wo ist der Unterschied zwischen PIN und Passwort? Ich würde sagen, PIN ist diese Geschichte mit Nummern, Block und nach 3 Mal falsch eingeben irgendwie warten und Passwort ist halt Passwort, wie man will. Würde ich jetzt mal vermuten.
Ha, UVP, UVP ist so dead. Das ist auch wieder so etwas, was Microsoft verschissen hat.
An sich finde ich, also das UI von UVP ist eine super Geschichte, also wenn man WPF und diese ganze SAML-Geschichte mag, ist das UI von UVP gut, der Rest drumherum ist furchtbar.
Zumal man als Hobby-Entwickler gar keine UVP-Apps programmieren kann, weil man ein Codesign-Zertifikat braucht und niemand, wirklich niemand, der hobbymäßig Anwendung entwickelt, hat ein Codesigning-Zertifikat für irgendwie 350€ im Jahr.
Zeitleutung ist einfach geworden, du brauchst aber immer noch ein gültiges Zertifikat.
Oder aber, oder aber, die Leute müssen, doch brauchst du, außer bei dir auf dem Rechner, oder aber die Leute müssen dein Self-Signed-Zertifikat akzeptieren.
Ja, ich weiß, dass Self-Signed geht, aber dann kriegen die Leute einen Pop-Up, wo sie erstens Admin-Rechte für brauchen, für Self-Signed, du brauchst Admin-Rechte für Self-Signed, um das in den Trust-Store einzufügen und die Leute müssen der Sache vertrauen.
Das ist Fail, das ist einfach nur Fail. Deswegen macht keiner hobbymäßig UVP-Apps. Ich hab kein neues Mikrofon, ich hab nur ein bisschen Kompressorsettings rumgestellt.
Du brauchst Admin-Berechtigung und die Leute müssen einen zusätzlichen Installer Schritt machen, indem sie dein Zertifikat vertrauen.
Was der normale User mal wieder überhaupt nicht checkt, so nach dem, was ist das für ein scheiß Installer, warum geht das nicht. Einfach Fail.
Deswegen macht auch niemand UVP-Apps. Ich hätte eine Idee. Microsoft könnte einfach auf ihre Seite schreiben, hier ISO-Download.
Hab ich euch eigentlich schon, hab ich, aber ich zeig's euch nochmal. Kennt ihr eigentlich den geilsten, den besten Windows Hack 2020? Den zeige ich euch jetzt hier.
Exklusiv hier, Windows-Hacksaw, Ultra-Hacksaw-Hyper-Trick. Jede nicht-UVP-App mit einem Installer, der nach, ja das stimmt, da hast du recht, aber ich installiere die meisten Sachen, die meisten Sachen brauchen keine Admin-Berechtigung.
So, also, geht nicht, man kann ja keine ISOs mehr runterladen von Microsoft, aber, jetzt kommt's, der Kommentator kennt's noch oder wusste's schon, man kann ja nur noch dieses komische Tool runterladen.
Aber, wenn man jetzt hier in die Browser-Settings geht und die mobile Ansicht einschaltet, dann, wow fuck, ich hab's kaputt gemacht, wenn man die mobile Ansicht einschaltet und erst mal reloadet, und ihr seht's, schon, schon kann man ein ISO runterladen.
Exzellent, oder? Schon kann man ein ISO runterladen. Easy. Man muss einfach seinen Browser auf Mobile Device stellen und schon kann man ein Windows ISO runterladen.
16bit, Windows 10, Englisch, ISO. Eats. Das ist mal Big Brain, oder? So muss das sein. Warum darf der Mauszeiger vor meinem Bild sein hier? Anzeige ist raus.
So, jetzt hab ich euch den Hyper-Windows-Hack gezeigt. Reveal. Nur hier. Worldwide First.
This option can be useful for achieving a cleaner, I guess, installation of Windows. Finally, Windows 10 version 2004 makes it easier to configure how you receive notifications on your PC.
When a notification post appears... Das Notification-Menü. Ich könnte jetzt ja wieder ne Umfrage machen. Verwendet jemand das Notification-Menü?
Ich guck da nie rein. Ich verwende es nicht. Ich hab schon mal im Stream gefragt, ob es Leute verwenden, und ich weiß, dass es tatsächlich ein paar Leute verwenden.
Um die Notifications loszulehnen. Ich verwende gar kein Windows. Ja, komm ich leider nicht drum herum. Würde ich auch gerne.
Ja, das verwendet irgendwie kein Mensch. Oder, wenige, wenige.
It'll have a little settings button now. This settings button will let you disable notifications from that app entirely, or view additional options for notifications from this app in the Windows settings.
Windows 10 ist mittlerweile so ein komischer Hybrid aus Touch, Mobile und Desktop-Betriebssystem, was an keiner Stelle weiß, was es sein will. Das ist der Wahnsinn.
SwiftPair is a feature supported by many Microsoft Bluetooth accessories. In Windows 10 Version 2004, connecting a supported SwiftPair device is now easier than before.
Simply press and hold the Bluetooth button on your accessory, and a notification will appear on your PC, prompting you to connect that device.
By clicking connect, your device will connect to your PC without any extra steps.
Äh, ist das nicht bei Bluetooth immer schon so? Okay, nee, nee, nee. Normalerweise muss man bei Bluetooth noch ein Code eingeben.
Ja, gut.
There are many more changes to this release of Windows 10, including extended language and accessibility support and major improvements to the Windows subsystem for Linux 2.
Träum, was haste denn um?
Das hat eigentlich einen ganz guten Witz am Ende gemacht, da ist es voll untergegangen.
Gut, ähm, ja. Wir wissen, dass nichts wirklich wahnbrechendes Neues kommt im neuen Windows. Juckt mich persönlich gar nicht.
Ja, das war Minecraft. Das hat man gesehen, als der den Kirchenturm gescreenshotted hat.
Geh, was macht denn der Auer Neues?
Wir haben eine AMD-CPU auf über 8,1 GHz getackt, oder kommt flüssig Stickstoff wieder an den Start?
Gucken wir uns mal an. Aber vielleicht spulen wir ein bisschen vor, wo es losgeht.
Hallo zusammen, herzlich willkommen zu einem weiteren Video. Heute machen wir flüssig Stickstoff-Overclocking und zwar mit einem AMD FX8000.
Wann kommt WSL2? Ist das nicht schon?
Die CPU besitze ich schon mehrere Jahre. Ich habe mir damals eine einzige von diesen CPUs gekauft, hatte einfach unfassbares Glück mit dieser CPU.
Lief extrem gut damals, war eine der besten CPUs, die es damals bei HWBoot gab. Ist, glaube ich, immer noch in den Top 20 CPUs der jemals am höchsten erreichten Frequenzen, wie auch immer.
Und damals habe ich das mit einem Asus Crosshair V-Formular gemacht, also einem Mainboard, das schon deutlich in die Jahre gekommen ist.
Und mittlerweile gibt es ja das Asus 79 Pro Gaming Aura, also gibt es ja auch schon seit einigen Jahren.
Pro Gaming Aura. Gute Mainboard-Namen.
Aber es ist ein deutlich besseres Board für Sockel AM3. Deswegen dachte ich, wir probieren das nochmal aus, ob wir die Ergebnisse reproduzieren können von damals oder vielleicht sogar übertreffen können, weil wir haben eine deutlich bessere Spannungsversorgung bei dem 79 Pro Gaming Aura.
Und ich habe auch noch zusätzlich ein relativ cooles Feature dran hier, diese kleine Platine. Ich würde jetzt sagen, ich zeige euch einfach mal, was das ist.
Ich habe es am Anfang nicht richtig aufgepasst. Was hat er denn für eine CPU?
Dieses Video wird unterstützt von der neuen Wireless-FPS-Gaming-Mouse.
Der macht genau die Sellouts, genau das entgegengesetzte Ende von Linus Tech Tips. Linus Tech Tips macht das immer so richtig smooth integriert und bei ihm denke ich immer, okay, er liest jetzt einfach den Zettel ab, den mir der Hersteller geschickt hat.
FX8000350. Ohje, das ist ja wirklich alt. Der liest das immer so geil ab.
Der liest das immer so geil ab. RGB-Kühler Beste.
3666C10. Sehr, sehr gute RAM-Riegel, werden wir aber nicht wirklich verwenden heute, weil wir eigentlich nur CPU-Z validieren wollen, vielleicht ein bisschen Cinebench machen wollen. Das ist so der Fokus für heute.
Und ihr seht hier oben, hier habe ich ein Kabel angelötet. Hier oben ist so ein Render.
Normalerweise sind da einfach nur drei Lötpunkte. Da ist nichts drauf. Ich habe dann eine Stiftleiste drauf gelötet und dann dieses Kabel angeschlossen. Und dieses Kabel geht zu dieser kleinen Platine.
Der Morpheus hat Subscribed. Dankeschön. Drei Monate. Huge Sub.
Hier seht ihr jetzt die L-More-EVC-2-Software. Hier angeschlossen an den i2C-Bus-1. Da klickt man hier einfach auf Find Device. Dann stellt er schon fest, wir haben hier den CHL3.
i2C habe ich noch nie gehört. Ich kenne nur die englische i2C, aber ich habe mir das noch nie überlegt, wenn man das auf Deutsch ausspricht.
Warum Windows für Overclocking? Ich vermute mal, weil es die ganze Software nur für Windows gibt, die die Profi-Overclocker benutzen.
8128, das ist unser Spannungswandler-Controller. Den kann man dann hier links auswählen. Dann hat man hier alle möglichen Werte, die im Spannungswandler hinterlegt sind. Also die Schaltfrequenz zum Beispiel 300kHz ist hier eingestellt.
Ah, excellent. Ich wollte immer schon mal die Schaltfrequenz von meinem Spannungswandler. Stell so neue, neue sich auch da an.
Hier ist alles schon hinterlegt. High-IQ-Software. Also auch natürlich von diesem Spannungswandler-Controller. Dann haben wir hier auch die volle Kontrolle.
Stimmt, die Software muss ja auf einem anderen Rechner sein, sonst könnte er ja nicht während er übertakte das benutzen.
Das habe ich schon gemacht. Gamer-VID-Type-Override. Und dann kann ich hier ganz einfach die CPU-Kernspannung extra einstellen.
Und das coole daran ist, viele Boards, gerade wenn die jetzt nicht unbedingt für Extreme-Overclocking gemacht sind, haben diverse Spannungslimits.
Also die können dann zum Beispiel nicht über 1,55 Volt gehen oder sowas. Und ihr seht, wenn ich jetzt hier runterscrolle, könnte ich problemlos 2,5 Volt einstellen.
Das wäre natürlich das Ende für die CPU, das wollen wir nicht. Aber wir können jetzt einfach mal beispielsweise 1,3 ist gerade eingestellt.
Dann stellen wir das auf 1,325. Ihr seht auch hier Output Voltage, das wird hier auch gerade...
Man sollte einfach seine CPU mit 48 Volt PoE betreiben für Maximum Overclock.
Aktiv gemessen. Wir haben hier nicht nur die CPU-Kernspannung, sondern wir haben auch die Leistung, was sehr interessant ist.
Wir haben hier immer wieder so Spitzen. Ich weiß nicht genau, was Windows da macht. Also im Idle immer so...
Das weiß Windows selber nicht.
10, 20 Watt, also interessante Lastspitzen, die da immer wieder kommen. Wenn wir jetzt auf Apply Changes gehen und drücken OK, dann seht ihr hier...
Exzellente Warnung, oder?
Also interessante Lastspitzen, die da immer wieder kommen. Wenn wir jetzt auf Apply Changes gehen...
Ah, write D2 gleich D330, alles klar.
Und drücken OK, dann seht ihr hier, da wo jetzt mein Cursor ist, hatten wir 1,3 Volt.
Wie zufrieden bist du mit dem Doorbird als Türsprecheranlage? Hatte ich mir nämlich auch mal angeguckt.
Wenn wir jetzt hier ganz nach rechts gehen quasi, auf den aktuellen Punkt, haben wir 1,326 Volt.
Also so können wir jetzt, wir laufen den Betrieb, ganz einfach die Kernspannung ändern, ohne, dass wir eine Software verwenden müssen am System.
Und ohne, dass wir ein spezielles BIOS brauchen, wo die Werte freigeschaltet sind. Also das ist wirklich eine extrem coole Sache.
Funktioniert mit einer riesen Anzahl von Mainboards und natürlich auch mit Grafikkarten. Also sehr, sehr interessantes Tool.
Das LMO-EVC ist da wirklich ein extrem hilfreiches Tool. Das haben wir auch schon in vielen von meinen Videos verwendet damals, als wir Epic zum Beispiel übertaktet haben.
Da kann man auch lustige Sachen mitmachen, wie Mainboard BIOS zu flashen, die eigentlich gar nicht dafür gedacht sind.
Wir haben damals zum Beispiel ein MSI BIOS auf ein ASUS Board geflashed, weil das EVC 2 auch erlaubt quasi einen Hardflash zu machen.
Man überschreibt einfach alles, was auf dem BIOS Baustein drauf ist.
So Sachen macht man aber nur, wenn man auf die Hardware nicht angewiesen ist.
Einfach mal so random, irgendwelche BIOS-Versionen, die nicht für das Board sind, zu flashen, ist glaube ich, wenn man den Rechner auch braucht, keine gute Idee.
Den kostet auch nur 35 Dollar, wenn ich es richtig in Erinnerung habe. Ich weiß auch nicht, wie lange es das Teil noch gibt.
Deswegen, falls ihr auch so viel experimentiert, kann ich euch nur ans Herz legen. Schaut euch das sehr, sehr gerne mal an.
Wie gesagt, erlaubt bei den meisten Mainboards und Grafikkarten die Spannung zu ändern, wenn es ein digitaler Controller ist.
Erlaubt aber das auch, wenn es kein digitaler ist. Das ist ein bisschen schwieriger.
Vielleicht covern wir das mal in einem extra Video, wie man das macht, wenn euch das interessiert.
Ansonsten habe ich das Setup soweit schon fertig vorbereitet. Windows ist drauf, EVC ist dran. Das EVC haben wir übrigens dran.
Das was?
Wenn wir die Frequenz ändern, gerade im absoluten Grenzbereich, dass wir dann nicht mehr die Spannung anfassen müssen.
Was? Was ist das EVC? Ah, okay. Das Ding, wo wir gerade das Toolphone gesehen haben?
Manchmal ist es auch so, wenn man sich in der Region von 7 GHz, 8 GHz bewegt und die CPU so am absoluten Limit läuft,
manchmal crash die dann so ein bisschen, wenn man zu sehr übers Limit geht. Wenn man dann die Spannung noch erhöht, dann fängt die sich manchmal wieder.
Dann kriegt man das System wieder stabil. Man kann das aber dann nicht am System selber machen, weil logischerweise dann die Software im Moment gar nicht funktionieren würde.
Deswegen ist es extrem hilfreich, das Ganze extern über einen extra Laptop zu machen. Dann hat man volle Kontrolle drüber, ohne per Software was ändern zu müssen.
Das ist der Grund, warum ich das gemacht habe und dass wir auch vielleicht interessanterweise, während wir extrem hohe Frequenzen haben, uns anschauen, wie verändert sich die Leistungsaufnahme von der CPU.
Oh mein Gott. Ich weiß nicht, was ich gerade mehr hassen soll, mich selbst oder mal wieder die AMD Halterung.
Also, die klebt mal wieder an den CPU.
Dann schön abkratzen jetzt.
Kühler, die CPU, ja. Und hier sind leider einige Pins verwogen, verdammt. Ich hoffe, ich kriege die gerade gebogen, oder dass die abbrechen. Ich würde mich wirklich, wirklich hassen, wenn das jetzt einfach in die Hose geht.
Wenn es abbricht, kein Problem, einfach wieder dranlöten. Eats.
Und passt's?
Ah, ja. Nice.
Okay, die CPU ist jetzt wieder im Sockel. Ich habe jetzt mal provisorisch noch mal schnell alles aufgebaut, bevor wir gleich anfangen, das Mainboard zu isolieren und alles vorzubereiten für Extreme Overclocking. Lieber noch mal schnell CPU einbauen, schauen, ob alles funktioniert. Dafür kurz noch eine ältere PCI-Debugkarte reingesteckt und dann schauen wir mal kurz, was passiert. Das sieht gut aus.
Moment.
Das Mainboard hat einen PCI? Sehe ich das richtig? Warum hat das Mainboard einen PCI?
Ah, das ist ja kein neues Mainboard. Das ist ja, ah, ja, ja, stimmt, hast du ja recht. Das ist ja, ich habe es ganz verdrängt, das ist ja eine uralt CPU. Das ist ja eine uralt, ja, ja. Ich war gerade, ich habe gerade, ja, ja, logisch.
Bei den CPUs der FX-Reihe, also alles, was 8.000er Generation ist, wie das hier oder auch 9.000er, 4.000er und so weiter, können wir Fullpot machen. Das bedeutet, wir füllen den Flüssig-Schickstoff-Container komplett, haben dadurch circa minus 190 Grad Celsius bei der CPU.
Und das führt natürlich dazu, dass da alles ziemlich schnell ein eist und auch relativ viel Kondenswasser sich bilden kann. Dementsprechend müssen wir das Board ein bisschen vorbereiten, weil das wurde noch nie verwendet für Flüssig-Schickstoff- oder Extreme-Overclocking.
Heißt, wir müssen die Heatsinks abbauen, weil hier ist es so, in dem Bereich, da ist es so kalt, da bildet sich kein Kondenswasser. Da wäre alles Eis, Eis ist nicht elektrisch leitfähig, da wäre es kein Problem.
In diesem Bereich, und gerade weil wir Abwärme hier drunter haben, bildet sich hier sehr schnell an dieser Grenze Kondenswasser. Bedeutet, Heatsinks abbauen und da drunter auf jeden Fall isolieren.
An dem Hobby muss man Spaß haben. Also, wirklich bringen tut es ja nichts. Das ist einfach so, wie ich auch an irgendwelchen Technik-Sachen stundenlang rumbasteln kann, einfach weil es nice ist und nicht weil es jetzt irgendwie großartig was bringt.
Das waren da Kühler oder generell Kühler mit Wärmeleitpads entfernt. Findet sich so ein Bild, das sieht dann aus, als wäre irgendwas ausgelaufen und das ist in der Regel einfach Silikonöl, das sich aus den Wärmeleitpads hier rausgelöst hat.
Kein Problem, ist ja auch nicht elektrisch leitfähig, aber wir wollen Flüssiggummi auftragen und dafür...
Flüssiggummi?
...mit ein bisschen Aceton abwischen.
Wenn ich was isolieren wollte, würde ich wahrscheinlich einfach mit meinem Heißkleber einmal drüberheißkleben und gut ist.
Du hast wahrscheinlich schlecht wieder abkriegst. Ja, das ist keine gute Idee, stimmt schon.
Wir brauchen ein Video mit dir und dem Bauer. Ich bin nicht der große Auferklocher, keine Ahnung, was man da zusammen machen könnte.
Fruchtbare Cooperation, zumal ich ja auf YouTube absolut nichts mache gerade.
Soweit ist jetzt wieder alles montiert, die Isolation ist getrocknet, jetzt noch Wärmeleitpaste drauf, CPU-Kühler montieren, Temperatursensoren, CPU-Kühler natürlich vorher...
Das ist hier für den Tank, oder? Dann.
Nicht vergessen und dann wieder alles montieren.
Wie kommt man einen flüssigen Stich drauf ran? Kann man wohl im Baumarkt holen oder so? Irgendeiner hatte mich letztens auch gefragt.
Und irgendjemand meinte, kriegt man im Baumarkt. Weiß ich nicht, ob das stimmt. Hab ich noch nie gekauft.
Hast du noch Kaffee?
Klar, der Frazier spielt komische Mobile-Games.
Wir hoffen, dass wir gegebenenfalls entstehendes Kondenswasser auffangen und dann geht's los.
Made in Germany. Ist das nicht gefährlich, den Stickstoff so reinzuschütten? Nö.
Musst halt treffen.
Alles klar, die Plattform läuft soweit. Ich hab jetzt kurz ein bisschen flüssig Schickstoff reingekippt, damit das Ganze nicht überhitzt.
Wir haben aktuell eine Temperatur am Kühlerboden von knapp 30 Grad Celsius.
Cinebench R15 läuft gerade durch im Multi und wir starten mit einem CPU-Takt von 3 GHz auf allen Kernen, weil wir ja nur ein Modul hochtakken wollen.
Die anderen drei Module bleiben ein bisschen niedriger.
Wie viele Kerne hatte das? Vier oder acht? Einer macht das garantiert nicht mit.
Skate Girl.
Die CPU hat ja richtig Strom gefressen damals.
WTF 160 Watt.
Hier rechts sehen wir z.B. auch sehr, sehr gut Spannungswandertemperatur war hier maximal bei 66 Grad Celsius, also auch sehr, sehr guter Wert.
Jetzt wird geschüttet. Blubber, Blubber, Blubber. Full Pot.
Jetzt wird es schön kühl.
Was ist das für eine CPU? Irgendeine uralte FX, ich hab vergessen, FX 8000, irgendwas.
Und jetzt wird das noch gepustet?
Ah, zieht der, ist das irgendwie das Gas, was da rauskommt oder so, für was ist der Lüfter?
Wegsaugen in Kondenswasser. Wow, was zum...
Warum hat er jetzt noch die Dings, die Heißluft rein gestorben? Warum? Verstehe nicht, das wurde zu kalt.
Im Moment habe ich folgendes Problem und zwar, es ist schon relativ kühl, wir haben hier ca. minus 125 Grad Celsius und wenn ich jetzt runterkühle auf minus 160, dann geht alles aus.
Also ich muss gerade herausfinden, warum wir einen Cold Bug auf dieser Plattform haben, was normalerweise bei diesen CPUs nicht der Fall sein sollte.
Ah, wenn es zu kalt ist, geht es kaputt. Cool. Jetzt bin ich bei minus 170 und es funktioniert noch.
Deshalb haben wir wieder einen typischen Vofi-Effekt. Ich sitze jetzt gerade seit einer halben Stunde an diesem Problem.
Gut, ich habe jetzt gerade im BIOS ein bisschen was umgestellt, habe ein paar Features deaktiviert, also ein paar CPU-Features, On-Board-Features.
Relativ kühl. Ach komm, es ist nur 170. Minus 170.
Wir sind jetzt gerade bei 1,9 Volt, das ist schon relativ viel.
Im MOEVC habe ich 1,85 V-Core, wir haben ca. 50-70 Watt gerade unter Last, obwohl wir nichts machen, das ist einfach nur, weil die Frequenz so hoch ist.
Das sieht man auch hier relativ gut, 30 Ampere. Die Spannungsfahnen lesen dann natürlich nur noch 1 Grad Celsius aus.
7.800. 1,9 Volt ist ordentlich. Ich weiß nicht, was die Dinger normalerweise für eine V-Core-Dingspannung hatten, aber 1,9 erscheint mir jetzt relativ hoch.
Wahrscheinlich ist normal 1,3 oder 1,2. Ich weiß nicht, was da normal ist.
1,3, das ist auf jeden Fall ordentlich.
Da haben wir es. Ach, hier hat es auf der CPU.
Was ist normal? Was hat der normal? FX 8350.
Was hat der normal?
Was ist Standard? Boost ist 4,2. Okay, das ist auf jeden Fall mehr als das Doppelte.
Hier sieht man übrigens sehr sehr gut, was Extreme Overclocking ohne Mainboard antun kann.
Ich hoffe, ihr könnt sehen, wie stark das Mainboard gebogen ist.
Und das ist nicht wegen dem Flüssig-Schickstoffkühler, der da drauf sitzt, sondern weil das alles so kalt ist und da unterschiedliche Kupferlayer drauf sind in unterschiedlichen Dicken, in unterschiedlichen Ebenen.
Und somit verzieht sich das Board durch die Kälte einfach enorm.
Erstmal schön draufklopfen.
80 Grad Celsius haben.
Aber im Moment läuft eigentlich alles ganz gut. Ich probiere es jetzt ungefähr zum zehnten Mal so Richtung 8,2 Gigahertz zu gehen.
Ist nicht ganz einfach, aber ich bin noch dran.
Vulkan. Kältevulkan.
Man sollte jetzt sich vielleicht nicht verschütten.
Das System läuft weiter fröhlich vor sich hin, ist natürlich mittlerweile schon gut eingeeist nach ca. zwei oder drei Stunden, die ich jetzt schon dabei bin, würde ich mal schätzen.
Und gerade mache ich noch einen Cinebench R15 Single Core Run bei knapp 7,5 Gigahertz, einfach mal rein aus Interesse.
Also man sieht schon, das dauert relativ lang, aber ich wollte einfach mal wissen, wie so eine CPU bei 7,5 Gigahertz ist von der Geschwindigkeit verglichen mit einer CPU heute stock.
Ich glaube, dass diese CPU selbst bei 7,5 Gigahertz noch deutlich langsamer sein wird.
172 Punkte, das ist gar nicht so schlecht, das ist so ein bisschen über dem Niveau von einem 4770K. Schauen wir mal, ob es noch höher geht.
Wir haben hier übrigens eine Leistungsaufnahme von ca. 100 Watt. Wenn man das bedenkt, dass es nur ein einzelner CPU kann, ist es natürlich schon echt enorm.
Damit sind wir jetzt auch tatsächlich schon am Ende angekommen, denn ich habe einfach keinen Flüssigstichstoff mehr.
Ich hatte insgesamt 30 Liter, die habe ich auch noch von einer anderen CPU genutzt, das Video kommt in einigen Wochen.
Trotzdem 8350, einfach sehr, sehr, sehr schöne CPU. Einfach die Tatsache, dass man damit relativ einfach 8 Gigahertz erreichen kann, was mit keiner anderen heutigen CPU möglich ist.
Egal, ob es ein aktueller Ryzen ist, egal, ob es eine aktuelle Intel CPU ist.
Die aktuellen Intel CPUs schaffen mit Flüssigstichstoff etwas über 7 Gigahertz, mit Flüssig Helium etwa 7,5, 7,7 Gigahertz, aber auch die erreichen keine 8 Gigahertz.
Dementsprechend sind diese CPUs Bulldozer wie Schera sehr, sehr speziell, machen absolut Spaß und war sehr, sehr cool, dass man wieder zu testen.
Auch interessant, dass so eine CPU mit knapp 8 Gigahertz von der Single-Core-Leistung nicht mal im Ansatz an den aktuellen Ryzen 3000 rankommt.
Da sieht man einfach, wie groß dann letztendlich doch die Technologie gesprungen ist.
Klar, in den letzten zehn Jahren hat sich was getan.
Man hätte natürlich im Single-Core-Score noch ein bisschen was rausholen können, wenn man den RAM jetzt weiter getwiegt hätte.
Aber der RAM lief relativ entspannt, dass ich einfach so hoch wie möglich takten kann und da kein Limit entsteht.
Damit hoffe ich, das Video hat euch gefallen.
Ja, nice Video. Ab und zu gucke ich dir immer gerne.
Das ist so richtig schön abgedrehtes Zeug.
Ciao.
Gigi eats easy.
Hat wirklich was weihnachtliches hier.
Cool.
So, was haben wir denn sonst noch so zu bieten?
Gamstar-Video zu Endzone. Was haben wir hier? Double Nuke.
Ich habe schon ewig kein MW2 mehr geguckt.
Der beste Burger. Linus, der sich über das neue MacBook auslässt.
Irgendwelche Schlösserknack-Sachen.
Der Black Mesa-Test, den wollte ich mir schon lange mal angucken.
Wie man eine Custom-Firmware für Smart-Cams mit Backdoors ausstattet oder so.
Was man mit einer Public-IP-Adresse machen kann, das ist wahrscheinlich irgend so ein...
Ich meine, die Bewertung ist schlecht.
Hast du Alex gespielt? Ich habe kein VR.
Linus, ja, guck mal.
Raspbian XP WTF.
Ah, warum? Warum macht man sowas freiwillig?
Come on, guys.
Muss das sein?
Was habe ich denn da auf? Rain-Gutter-Power, also sprich...
Wie heißt es? Regenrinne.
Energiegewinnung aus Regen... WTF, was ist mit den Leuten los?
Tour of my home-Network.
Und war Windows ME wirklich so schlecht? Das können wir nachher auch noch gucken.
Ok, guck mal den MacBook-Hate an.
The MacBook Air had two fatal flaws. Apple's butterfly keys were a disaster.
And the dual-core processor kneecapped any potential for serious multitasking.
Both of these are now fixed in the 2020 model.
But now the MacBook Air has two even bigger problems.
Dell...
Seit wann hat er eigentlich einen Bart? Seit Corona?
And HP are now building laptops that not only outperform the MacBook Air,
but also manage to match its legendary build quality.
So what to recommend then?
A laptop for sure.
But which one? We'll find out after this word from our sponsor, of course.
Thanks World of Tanks for sponsoring this video.
World of Tanks, geh mal vorn.
Da habe ich bisher alles abgelehnt, was ich gekriegt habe zu World of Tanks.
Alles, komplett.
Wollte ich nichts mehr zu tun haben. Ich hab wirklich alles.
Und die sind ja schon seit Jahren immer wieder am Start mit irgendwas.
Ist das bisschen zu laut, hä?
Watt? Moment.
Ach nee, das ist Dell. Wollte grad sagen.
3,5 Millimeter Klinke? Was ist denn mit Apple auf einmal los?
MacBook haben noch 3,5 Millimeter Klinkerohr. Poggers.
Ganz ehrlich, die eingebauten Speaker jucken mich überhaupt nicht.
Kopfhörer dran gut ist.
Videocalls würde ich im Leben nicht über Speaker machen,
damit Kopfhörer aufgesetzt, Headset oder sonst was gut ist.
Aber es ist doch eigentlich vollkommen egal.
Selbst wenn Dell und was ist der andere?
Dell und was ist das? Lenovo? Nee, was ist das?
HP.
Selbst wenn HP und Dell bessere Notebooks bauen als Apple,
da ist immer noch kein Mac OS drauf.
Und offiziell supported. Installieren kann man es bestimmt.
Das ist doch das, warum viele Leute Macs kaufen.
Erstens wegen der ganz guten Qualität an sich.
Wenn auch ein paar fragwürdige Entscheidungen.
Aber die meisten Leute, die ein Apple-Gerät kaufen wollen,
wollen doch gerade Mac OS haben. Und das haben sie hier nicht.
Das kann er echt immer gut.
Also ich würde mir lieber das 30 Kilo Notebook kaufen,
was der Bauer da letztens vorgestellt hat.
Das war gar nicht so schwer.
Ich weiß, aber es war ein riesen fettes Ding mit irgendwie 40 Minuten Nacko-Laufzeit.
Wisst ihr was, die beste Notebook-Tastatur ist keine Notebook-Tastatur.
Ja okay, das leuchten wir ein.
Auch eine Sache, die mir immer auf den Keks geht bei Notebook-Tastaturen.
Ich fühle mich diskriminiert.
Warum dürfen auf dem MacBook Air 92% der Frauen ordentlich schreiben und nur 77% der Männer?
Was ist da los? Abmahnung ist raus?
Was ist da los?
Das stimmt, da hat er recht.
13 Zoll Display ist jetzt auch nicht groß.
Das ist halt ein Thema, was komplett an mir vorbeigeht,
weil das Notebook, was ich verwende auf der Arbeit, verwende ich eigentlich 99% stationär.
Daheim habe ich kein Notebook, was ich regelmäßig verwende, da verwende ich nur meinen Desktop.
Ja.
Ja gut, da brauchst du aber einen Mac Watch.
Smartwatch ist eine Sache, so ein Trend ist wirklich auch an mir vorbeigegangen.
Ich bin froh, dass ich keine Uhr mehr anziehen muss, seitdem ich ein Smartphone habe.
Es sei denn, die einzige Sache, die ich verstehe, ist als Fitness-Tracker.
Das ist okay, das leuchtet mir noch irgendwo ein.
Mich würde es eher nerven, wenn ich wieder eine Uhr anziehen müsste.
Bringen wir uns zu Mac OS.
Ich bin jetzt an dem Punkt, wo ich nicht wirklich verstehe, was das Haste ist.
Ja, es wird ein paar Tage dauern, für eine technisch-savage Person, um sich an die verschiedenen Schottkarten und den generellen Arbeitslauf zu verwenden.
Aber wie web-zentrisch alles, was wir jetzt tun, ist,
ich denke, dass für viele Menschen, außer von App-Kompatibilität, was auch immer du professionell machst,
die Tatsache, dass du auf einem komplett anderen Operierungssystem bist, wird wahrscheinlich in den Hintergrund fallen.
Die einzige Sache, die mich kontinuierlich anstrengt,
war, dass, um ein Fenster aufzunehmen, muss ich langdrehen, vollscreenen, und dann dieses dumme Menü benutzen.
Warum muss ich denn ein bezahltes App installieren, um eine ordentliche Windows-Snapping-Funktionalität zu bekommen?
Oh, Microsoft... Er könnte, er könnte ja auch, er könnte ja auch i3-WM unter Linux verwenden, dann hat er gar keine Probleme mehr.
Aber dafür hat er viele andere Sachen, die nicht mal funktionieren.
Windows-Snapping? Das ist ein dickes Move.
Dickes Move.
Anyway, everything's been pretty positive so far, and I promised a problem here, didn't I? I could point out its webcam, especially right now, with work from home.
Ja, aber Umut, meine Frage. Wenn du ein Alert auf die Apple Watch bekommst, wenn dein Server nicht mehr läuft,
wo ist der Vorteil davon, den Alert auf die Apple Watch zu bekommen, anstatt sie einfach aufs Smartphone zu bekommen?
Aufs Smartphone hast du ja sogar mehr Displayplatz, dass du was sehen kannst.
Quite frankly, all of them are bad, so I guess we're gonna have to wait for someone.
Sway hab ich nur mal kurz ausprobiert, und Wayland hat mich abgefuckt.
...to make the first move, and this isn't gonna be it. But there's a bigger one. It's performance.
For some reason, Apple has decided to include only a Wi-Fi 5 network card, which probably isn't a huge deal right now, but as Wi-Fi 6 becomes more commonplace...
Also bei so einem teuren Notebook würde ich das auch erwarten.
...13 and X360 owners are going to enjoy significantly faster Wi-Fi.
And as for the processor, well, the base model still has a dual-core i3, which we find truly unacceptable in 2020.
Even something like a background app install or an update can make a dual-core machine feel sluggish.
But the good news is, even if it costs extra, at least you can get a quad-core in the MacBook Air now.
So for our config, we chose the i5-1030NG7 for its decent balance between price and performance.
Unfortunately, it's not actively cooled, or at least not directly.
There is a fan in the chassis, but there's no heatpipe on the small wimpy heatsink assembly for the CPU connecting it to some kind of radiator and the exhaust of that fan.
What that means is that the MacBook Air 2020 only has about 10 watts of CPU power to play with before it would overheat.
So, needless to say then, it gets absolutely flogged by the XPS 13 and Spectre X360 with their 25 watts of available CPU power.
Consuming less power means more battery life though, right?
Well, the thing is, it's hard to directly compare battery life results between Mac OS and Windows.
But in our testing, the MacBook Air and the XPS 13 both got a bit over 10 hours away from the wall, while the Spectre X360 kept going for an additional hour.
Which makes recommending the MacBook Air slightly difficult.
The feel in the hand, the display, the keyboard and speakers, like all the parts that you would interact with regularly, are excellent.
But as a fact, this is a $1500 machine that will fall behind very fast if you try to do more than browsing the web and writing that novel you've been working on.
That said, heaps of people don't need to do much more than that.
And with the improved keyboard, it really is a lot better, and the additional power, which really is a lot better, this is a much more compelling machine than last gen.
Furthermore, no matter what the price or performance, the XPS and the X360 are also really expensive, and they will never come with Mac OS for the people who care about that.
So, in a total over...
Yeah, it's flawed, but I'm ready to recommend the 2020 Air to anyone that doesn't need maximum performance and is willing to spend a little bit more money on it.
And then, for those who do need the performance, there are rumors of a new MacBook Pro 13-inch that might really make these Windows machines sweat.
So, make sure you're subscribed for that face-off.
Speaking of face-off...
Windows ME, was war es wirklich so schlecht?
Ach, das muss ich mir jetzt sagen kommen, ja.
Also, bevor ich anfange zu erzählen, meine Erinnerung an Windows ME.
Ich meine, das dürfte dieses Jahr 20 Jahre alt werden.
Meine Erinnerung...
Oh, da bin ich alt, ey.
Das ist 20 Jahre her.
Ich kann mich immer noch dran erinnern, wo ich den Scheiß installiert hab.
WTF.
So lang ist das her, das ist doch nicht normal.
F.
RIP.
Ähm...
Ja, also meine Erfahrung zu...
Windows ME, ich hab den Hate damals nicht so ganz verstanden, muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Es war genauso scheiße wie Windows 98.
Also, wenn man die Windows 95 Linie scheiße findet, dann findet man auch Windows ME scheiße.
Aber für die damalige Zeit im Heimbereich zum Spielen war das halt das einzige, was vorhanden war.
Und da war Windows ME genauso kacke wie Windows 98 oder genauso gut wie Windows 98.
Das gab eigentlich kaum Unterschiede.
Nur, dass Windows ME ein bisschen hübscher ausgesehen hat.
Windows 98 war dann irgendwann schon ziemlich angestaubt.
Aber glücklicherweise gab es ja dann Windows 2000.
Mehr oder weniger parallel.
Auf dem man auch schon sehr viele Sachen machen konnte.
Und spätestens mit Windows XP...
Ähm... mit Windows XP war die Sache eh gegessen.
Nur kann ich verstehen, ja.
So ein abschließendes Fazit wäre bei vielen Review Videos wirklich gut.
Aber ist das original verpackt?
Ist das ein original verpacktes Windows ME?
Hier unten sieht man den Plastik.
Ein original verpacktes Windows ME.
Das musst du erstmal finden noch.
Nicht öffnen, ja.
Da ist wahrscheinlich von...
Man kriegt ein bisschen Geld zu.
Geöffnet ist man bei null.
Ok, ok, ich merke Suffice.
Ok, dann offen wir das practe Produkt ein bisschen einعدender.
Ist das 15-wirtschaftsmittel.
nicht öffnen ja da ist wahrscheinlich von man kriegt ein bisschen geld zu geöffnet ist man bei
null
20 jahre von den Leuten die es aufbauen. Ich meine, es wird einfach eine der wichtigsten
Warte mal, wann kam das dann raus?
Ich glaube 2000 oder 99
Ja september 2000 september 2000
Ja guck mal Windows XP war auch nicht mehr lange hin so und Windows 2000 gab es auch schon
ja
Deswegen ich habe es auch nicht lange verwendet
After my wine den heiligen kann ich noch dran erinnern oder scheiß das muss ich jetzt echt mal sagen
Du, wo mir gerade wieder auffällt wie alt ich bin ich kann mich noch dran erinnern
Wo wir die beta version von windows xp installiert haben ich habe wistler hieß da kram windows wistler oder so war das nicht
Windows xp
Aber die beta version von windows xp installiert
Und fanden den plau fanden den die die wie den wiesen hintergrund damals haben uns folge folge hyped auf die wiese
Weiß ich was man an so einer wiese toll finden kann
Gibt es einen grund warum du immer an eins hinschreibst ja
Wache mal ausrufe zeichen eins ausgeschrieben im chat so scheiße war das nicht das war genau so gut und schlecht wie
Winners 98
Definitiv die bessere wahl nur manche spiele ging damals hat man nicht das war so der die umbruch die umbruchzeit
Wo auch die x und sachen noch ein bisschen probleme unter 2000 hatten
Und spiele auch aber das wurde dann immer zunehmend besser
So dass man spätestens windows xp konnte konnte man umsteigen wenn aus xp habe ich ziemlich zur release gleich geholt beste
Not even bother changing anything with their os at all
Especially since windows xp was just around the corner in october 2001
This came out in well it was released to manufacturing in june 19th of 2000 and actually hit store shelves september 14th 2000
Meaning that it remained current for a little over a year and that was that now as for my own personal thoughts as to
Whether or not this was really as bad as everyone says well to be honest at the point i'm recording this at this very moment
I haven't used it in at least 18 years. Yeah, I have my compact bersario 5000 us
It came pre-installed on there. I used it for a year. Was ist das für eine komische wurst?
Was ist das für eine komische wurst
Du gehst jetzt pennen mich erinnert an schlafgut
Das ist komische wurst ja
Even it just got so unstable at that point that i did actually downgrade to windows 98 second edition
And that worked a lot better at least in my recollection
I don't actually know of the specifics. Aber das war mal eine zeit lang tatsächlich ein trend
Es war tatsächlich mal eine zeit langen trend
Dass man versucht hat alles möglichst möglichst rund und weich zu bauen
What was causing the instability either way i was not a fan of it. Ihr kennt ja bestimmt auch diese ergonomische keyboards von damals
I've always had weird feelings about me ever since and yes it is officially pronounced me just the way it's spelled there
You'll often hear it said me and as far as i'm concerned. That's legitimate as well
But if you look at old articles in the press, ich bin eher auch der windows m e sager and such
You got journalists and microsoft reps were repeatedly making the point back then that it was meant to be said me
For better or worse and the marketing reflected this there were lots of meet me ads and
Me is the operating system for me and things like that. It's still an initialism standard
It's still an initialism standing for millennium edition, of course
But the pr really wanted to try and differentiate it for microsoft
Microsoft benahmung microsoft benahmung war damals schon genauso schlecht wie heute entirely sold at the same time
It was really meant for business and enterprise users a proper successor to windows nt 4.0
Whereas millennium edition was meant to be the next big mainstream consumer operating system
And originally it was actually going to be based on the nt kernel and file system like windows 2000 was but
Mir fällt da immer zu ein wenn ich windows 2000 sehe
Wo man wieder sieht dass noobs eine ganz andere verbindung zu technik haben als leute die sich damit auskennen und zwar mein vater der hatte
Damals den amd duron 800
Und
Das war ist ein uraltes ding ja also das ist das ist so alt das war man das
2000 drum auch so ja so und da hatten wir dann auch da hatten wir dann auch windows 2000 drauf und
Der sagt bis heute bis heute aber wahrscheinlich weil es einfach so angenehm war von windows 98 auf 2000 umzusteigen
Der sagt heute noch mein amd duron das war der beste rechner den ich je hatte
Als hat die cpu mit als hat die low budget als hat die low budget cpu damit irgendwas zu tun
Das war der umstieg von windows 98 und windows 2000
Der ihm so gut gefallen hat und nicht die cpu
Die dinger konnte man aber glaube sogar ganz gut übertanken damals
Guck mal cpus wo man noch was mit bloßem auge erkannt hat
In den detaillieren der erarbeitung ist in der faktur ist eine von den science elfen die ich gesehen habe nicht zu lange
Vorher empfehle ich das aber gerade jetzt bin ich mehr interessiert in zu sehen ob oder nicht es wirklich die beste internet experience war
tja
Damals hatte ich auch noch internet explorer was war das internet explorer 5 oder so oder 4
Und ich bilde mir ein es gab damals schon die erste firefox version
den noch firebird hieß der
firefox hieß ja mal firebird bevor es firefox
hieß
gibt es eine ordentliche version das war 02 oder sowas
Das kommt doch ungefähr hin von der zeit her initial release
Ja genau das sah noch so komisch aus das firebird logo
Ja, only two
Aha
Wann war der Release?
Die Seiten sind übel, das ist unübersichtlich, wow!
Hier, hier sieht man es schön, Firefox Timeline.
Ok, ne, das muss dann doch ein Ticken später gewesen sein mit Firefox.
2002 ist ein bisschen spät für Windows ME.
Äh, ja genau, das Thunderbird ist das Mail- bzw. PIM-Programm.
Den Netscape habe ich nicht mehr verwendet, Netscape hat mir damals auch nicht gefallen.
Meine erste Website habe ich mit dem Netscape Composer gemacht.
Kennt ihr noch jemand? Netscape Composer.
Kennt noch jemand Netscape Composer?
Huge Software hier, PC-Welt-Testpager, ja, so sah der Kram aus.
Netscape Composer, das war so ein Visivic-Editor für HTML.
Und danach habe ich abgecradet, da habe ich mir gedacht, ok, damit kann man keine ordentlichen Websites machen.
Frontpage habe ich nie richtig verwendet, damit kann man keine ordentlichen Websites machen.
Und dann habe ich das verwendet, was alle coolen Leute so 2000 rum verwendet haben.
Dreamweaver, so irgendwie 2000 rum oder so.
Macromedia Dreamweaver, ja, exellent, genau, der Kram hier.
Und damit konnte man tatsächlich ganz gute Websiten machen für die damalige Zeit.
Die hatten auch eine ziemlich gute Autovervollständigung.
Moment, was? Es gibt ein Tutorial für Dreamweaver 8?
Im Hintergrund hörst du... Warum ist das ein Video von 2014 für Dreamweaver?
What the fuck?
Huge Tutorial, Wahnsinn.
Gut, aber jetzt kommen wir zum eigentlichen Video mal zurück.
Hättest du mal... Wer von euch hat auch Dreamweaver verwendet damals?
Falls es euch überhaupt schon geben hat.
Ah, okay, hab ich.
Echt? Gab es das?
Warte mal.
Ach, 210. Boah, war das teuer. 210 Dollar für Windows ME. Fuck, war das teuer.
Jetzt kann ich das ja machen, das ist ja schon verjährt.
Ich bin mir eigentlich ziemlich sicher, dass ich für Windows ME damals nichts bezahlt habe.
What?
Das ist aber auch ein High-Skill-Messer, was er da hat.
Ist das ein Klappteppichmesser? Sehe ich das richtig?
Das ist ein klappbares Teppichmesser.
Excellent.
Eigentlich coole Sache.
Minus 200 Euro, Leute.
Grip.
Einfach wieder einschweißen danach.
Oh, Holo, Holo-CD.
Die Boot-Discette ist auch dabei.
Cool.
Fast schon wie ein Geldschein.
You are important to us steht auf der Diskette.
Ich hab noch eine Windows-890-CD irgendwo.
Ich hab irgendwo noch eine Windows-Nach-Leuchtsch-CD.
Die war damals überall drinne, AOL-CDs.
Du wurdest voll geschissen mit AOL-CDs.
AOL hat es auch ziemlich verschissen.
Das war eines der größten Provider und Sachen, die es überhaupt gab.
Aber jetzt ist nichts mehr voll übrig.
Oh, die Postkrastatenbank hat Kekse verschwendet.
Stimmt, das war das erste Windows mit Internet-Connect-Sharing.
Ich kenne auch noch jemand, ICS, Internet-Connection-Sharing.
Das haben wir damals auch verwendet.
Da habe ich einem Kumpel aus der Schule zusammen bei mir daheim gesessen.
Ich habe Internet-Connection-Sharing angemacht.
Oh, nee.
Gab es das auch bei 890 schon?
Ich kann mir daran erinnern.
Internet-Connection-Sharing hat sogar ganz gut funktioniert.
Das hat natt gemacht.
Da konntest du einfach deine Internetverbindung.
Das Modem hat es dir damals direkt am Rechner dran.
Deswegen wurden ja auch so viele Windows-Rechner mit billigster Software gehack-sort.
Das Modem war direkt am Rechner dran.
Dann hast du die Internetverbindung geshared.
Dann hast du einfach nut-router gemacht.
Nichts großartiges Besonderes.
Aber dann haben wir relativ schnell festgestellt,
dass Internet-Connection-Sharing sackt.
Dann haben wir das hier verwendet.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es das jetzt noch gibt.
Von Lilux und Sachen hatten wir damals keinen Plan.
Von richtiger Netzwerk-Hardware hatten wir auch keinen Plan.
Wir haben das hier verwendet damals.
Hier, 4.0, 4.2.
Das haben wir damals verwendet für Netzwerk-Freigabe,
dass andere Rechner im Netzwerk auch das Internet verwenden konnten.
WinRootLite.
Genau das Ding.
WinRoot. Genau, WinRoot.
Ja, ja, ja.
Dieses olle Zeug.
Ich weiß nicht, warum man es immer da für einen Knopf gibt.
Und danach gab es so eine komische Fake Firewall.
Ja, ja, ja. Nice, nice, nice.
Da hast du die ganzen Namen.
Die Sachen, mit denen man anfängt, merkt man sich eh.
Das brennt sich irgendwie ein.
Ich weiß nicht, was ich vor 5 Minuten im Chat gesagt habe,
aber ich weiß es noch.
Basically telling you the basics.
That's that, man.
Und am Ende noch mal die Lizenzbedingungen.
This is all you get inside here.
Let's get this delightful looking CD installed
on the LGR Megaluminum Monster.
Er hat ja BNC mit Terminator hatte ich auch noch.
Guess now it's gonna have Millennium Edition on it.
Das kennt heute, glaubt keiner mehr.
BNC-Kabel mit Terminator.
Keine Uhr.
Nee, er hat keine Uhr dabei gehabt,
weil die Uhr war nur bei den ersten 25.000 Exemplaren dabei.
You see it.
It will be booted into Windows Me.
Let's get this CD in here.
Bloop, bloop.
Ah, der Sound, hm?
Excellent.
CD-ROM contains a newer version of Windows
than the one you're presently using.
Would you like to upgrade it? Yes.
I mean, we don't have to do it from here.
We could just reboot and do things like that.
But yeah, why not?
Or on the fly.
Sort of.
Yeah, I'm just gonna try the upgrade version of this first.
Just taking 98SE and upgrading to Millennium Edition.
Da läuft wirklich Musik beim Upgraden.
I've read mixed results may occur.
So that could be fun.
And if it's a complete disaster, we will try a clean install.
But upgrade is first.
Welcome to Windows Me Setup.
I'm looking forward to your recommendations
on choosing Windows Millennium Edition.
I'm not sure if I chose it or if you guys chose it
by requesting it for years, but anyway.
There we go.
Now checking my hard disk for problems.
There is no hard disk.
This is running off of SD cards.
There's a SCSI 2 SD installed in here,
which is nice because I don't plan on keeping this
running Millennium Edition after this.
So I can just swap back to a Windows 98 SD card.
I've got them cloned and everything,
so I actually just swap them out all the time.
But anyway, behind the scenes stuff.
Windows just got better.
Helps you get the most out of your computer.
Diese Fotos hatten sie in den 90ern übelst gerne.
Solche, solche.
Das haben sie ja heute noch.
Ganze Familie vor Notebook und freut sich.
Aber so Fotos hatten sie damals besonders gerne.
Und diese Sache, dass Windows wurde besser.
Und Windows ist das beste Windows, das es je gab.
Das kann man in jedem Installer.
Windows Media Player, da wo es noch einen ordentlichen
Media Player gab, den man sogar skinnen konnte und alles.
Es ist teilweise erstaunlich zu sehen,
was wir in manchen Bereichen für Rückschritte gemacht haben.
Man konnte Windows XP und die ganzen ollen Windows XP Programme,
die konnte man alles stylen, customize, bis zum geht nicht mehr.
Und heute hast du ein Windows Mail Programm,
was noch nicht mal richtig Bilder runterladen kann.
Winamp.
Moment, Winamp Llama?
Wer kennt das noch?
Llama.
Winamp.
Das hat sich auch eingebrannt.
Stimmt, MSN Messenger.
Stimmt, Windows Movie Maker.
Der war gar nicht so schlecht.
Ah, yes.
3DFX Tools.
Hat er noch Voodoo drinne?
Ah, Joysticker Pod.
Oh.
Das war doch cool.
Und heute hast du einen Media Player dabei,
wo du nicht mal Dateien öffnen kannst.
Ja, guck mal.
Groove Music.
Wenn ich da Dateien öffnen will,
kann ich keine Dateien öffnen.
Ich hab bis heute nicht verstanden,
wie ich hier Dateien öffne drin.
Ich bin da einfach zu dumm für.
Ich weiß nicht, wie man Dateien öffnet.
Ich bin nicht in der Lage,
in dem neuen Media Player Dateien zu öffnen.
Es gibt keinen Knopf für, es gibt nichts.
Ich weiß nicht, wie man Dateien öffnet.
Track and Drop geht übrigens nicht.
Ah, RIP.
Flimmer, flimmer, flimmer, flimmer.
Sechs Chats.
Ah, yes.
Ja, die waren richtig mies.
Ich fand's aber cool,
dass man das skinnen kann irgendwo.
Man konnte das komplette Windows skinnen.
Ja, finde ich auch.
Es ist merkwürdig.
Das war eine neue Sache.
Geht das heute noch?
Kann man heute noch Windows ME updaten?
Übers Internet?
Funktioniert der Updater noch?
Ja, das hatte ich auch.
Das hatte ich auch.
Ja, genau.
Den Crap hatte ich auch damals.
Stimmt.
Die Sounds, wenn du Fenster animiert hast.
Echt, war das neu?
War das neu?
Irgendwie hab ich Gefühl,
das gab's schon immer.
Oh, auf die noch gehen bestimmt nicht.
Die gehen nicht mehr.
Die sind abgeschaltet.
Die gehen bestimmt nicht mehr.
Das gibt's nicht mehr.
Pinball, ja.
Es gab da auch einen Level-Editor für...
Da hab ich relativ viel rumgespielt früher.
Die Sounds, huge Sounds.
RIP.
Ist das Flash?
So Cringe-Videos hatten die damals gerne.
Ja...
Ich auch nicht.
Ich wusste gleich, dass es diminutriere Dir an dem day so und so.
Hard-Disk-Späße wie 150 oder 200 Megabit pro Restore-Point und
Runnig Dinge in der Hintergrund und
Zulassern des Computers, also kamen wir zu einer
Släufigeren Leistung als Windows 98.
Aber da ist es, wir haben einen Restore-Point gegründet.
Schaut euch das neue Hilf- und Unterstützung-System an.
Ja, das war ziemlich vorangehend, Mann,
als das Windows 98 hatte.
Das war eine halbe Stunde Laden.
Das war eine Art Encyclopedia-Design.
Das war noch pre-Internet-Wikipedia und alles.
Die Leute haben sich davon gewünscht, weil es nicht mit dem Manual kam.
Verdammt, ah, hier geht's los.
Der Movie Maker, jawoll.
Schaut euch das an.
Woah.
Hahaha.
Okay.
Musik für jede...
Yup.
Do I have anything to import?
Da ist ein Sample-File, das ist gut.
Oh, schaut euch das an.
Es hat automatisch diese Klips gemacht.
Huge-Quality.
Hahaha.
Oh, das ist die beste Qualität.
Okay.
Huge-Quality.
So, wir können das zusammen editieren.
Das hier.
Und dann machen wir ein Beck-Bitmap.
Importieren.
Ich denke, wir können nur Wave-File machen.
Es hat ein paar...
Es hat ein paar Sound-Effekte.
Hahaha.
Das wird das beste Video sein.
Ich glaube nicht, dass du hier
Stattik-Text-Boxen oder so
oder so einstattet.
Ich bin vielleicht falsch, ich weiß nicht.
Aber ich sehe das nicht.
Hahaha.
Huge-Video.
Das ist geil.
So viel habe ich als Sound-Bitrate eingestellt.
Das ist meine Sound-Bitrate gerade.
Was High-Quality-Video bei denen ist.
Hahaha.
Huge-Quality.
Aber was geil ist, damals hat man sich
darüber gefreut, über den Scheiß.
Hahaha.
Genial.
Das Video müsste man heute
interviewen, die alle stimmt.
Haha.
Akten... Aktenordner? Aktenordner, kann das sein? Aktenkoffer! Aktenkoffer hieß es auf Deutsch, genau.
Ähm, Arbeitsmappe? Arbeitsmappe war glaub ich in Visual Studio was anderes.
Ähm, zumindest, ich hab den Sinn davon nie verstanden.
But others worked perfectly fine.
What the fuck?
So yeah, Jazz Jackrabbit, it works.
But then you have games like Epic Pinball that aren't ideal running under windows, you get some like weird choppiness with the scrolling?
Skipped...
Yeah, I never liked that.
Tearing.
So yeah, if you could run that under actual DOS mode, then that'd be great.
Normally you'd just be able to go in here and create like a PIF or whatever.
You'd just tell it to go into DOS mode, but it's straight up not even an option anymore.
Do it 3D though, I mean, no.
Geht das eigentlich immer noch? Zwar blöd, aber kann ich immer noch Shortcuts erstellen unter Windows?
Und die Vorschau-Icons ändern? Also nehmen wir jetzt mal das hier, sagen Create Shortcut.
Kann ich immer noch die Icons ändern? Geht das? Change Icon.
Oh, guck mal, das ist das Windows 95 Icon-Feld. Da hat sich nichts getan seit 20 Jahren.
Guck mal, kein Unterschied.
Das ist ja wirklich kein Unterschied mehr.
Die Bilder sehen auch noch gar nicht so hässlich aus wie in Windows 95.
Da hat sich ja gar nichts getan bei Microsoft, ey, was ist das?
MSN, ja, das MSN-Icon brauch ich unbedingt dafür.
Sieht man mal, was Windows 10 mittlerweile für eine Ansammlung aus unterschiedlichsten Zeiträumen ist.
Ja, das wollte ich schon immer mal für die Datei haben hier.
Ja, exzellent.
Hast du Windows 5 noch nicht selber benutzt? Ja klar.
Das war die Zeit, wo die Eltern gedacht haben, Mortal Kombat ist das schlimmste Spiel aller Zeiten.
Weil er so gewaltverherrlichend und verrohend und so, oder?
Die Eltern wären fortnite für das schlimmste Spiel. Ja, da haben sie es ja auch recht.
Das war noch was. Damals hast du so viele sinnlose Sachen in Windows rumtrocknet,
in Systemordner und alles in der Hoffnung, danach hat es funktioniert,
irgendwelche Hacks, irgendwelche komischen DLLs aus dem Internet geladen,
registriert und geguckt, ah, jetzt funktioniert es.
Ich habe sogar einmal die Explorer Exe von Windows 890 rübergeschoben zu Windows ME
und das hat glaube ich auch funktioniert, nur dass irgendwelche Menüs nicht funktionierten und so.
Ganz merkwürdig.
Exo. Ja, das ist schon mit 15, oder?
Huge DOS-Menü.
Man kann heute übrigens noch ein Explorer Fenster von Windows 3L finden, in Windows 10, echt?
Das System.
Ah, der braucht schon DOS.
Also, echt war das so?
Ja, An The Tournament hatten wir am Start, Half Life 1 hatten wir am Start.
Damals fand man sich so geil bei der Grafik, aber man hat gesagt, boah, ist das krass.
Na ja, Heldchen kennen.
Die Zeit als Need for Speed noch gut war.
FRAPS. Die schlechteste Recording Software aller Zeiten, FRAPS.
3D Mark 2000.
Was war der 3D Mark 97, wo man mit dem Drache im Kreis geflogen ist?
Das war glaube ich 3D Mark 97 oder so.
Weie!
Ich habe mich über die Jahre Stück für Stück auf den Weg gebracht,
so toll wie möglich die gleichen Spiele zu spielen, die ich will,
in der gleichen Art und Weise, die ich will.
Das ist alles solide Hardware mit exzellentem Verkaufssupport.
Und ich hatte bereits gut gemachte Fahrzeuge und Software
und bin bereit, auf 98SE zu gehen,
als Millenium Edition die Reine hier nahm.
Also habe ich es wirklich die beste Chance gegeben, es zu erzielen,
und ich denke, das ist vielleicht einer der Gründe, warum es so gut funktioniert.
In Bezug auf den komischen Zeitpunkt,
kam er in Bezug auf Dinge wie hohe Soundqualität,
Hardware von Grafiken,
schmutzige 56K Modems,
verdammte Printer- und Scanner-Software,
schmutzige Schmutzige Modems,
Ich muss sagen, das ist zwar ziemlich...
Das war damals nicht schön zu benutzen, teilweise,
und auch die Videos und so, die Sounds und Themes,
das war schon ein bisschen cringe, alles...
Irgendwie hat das den gewissen Scham.
Ich kann mir das auch nicht erklären.
Oh, die Klammer!
Das stimmt.
Karl Klammer war der Beste.
Ich weiß, Microsoft hat es versucht,
Boot-Zeiten zu erhöhen und Konflikte zu minimieren,
und ja, es ist schneller zu starten,
und ich habe bisher noch keine Blu-Screens von Tod gehabt.
Aber der Verlust ist nicht wirklich wert,
zumindest nicht auf dieser Maschine.
Das Wichtigste ist,
ich denke, ich werde es an einem anderen PC instead installieren.
Etwas, das ich nicht so oft für LGR-Tipps benutze.
Weil, ich weiß nicht, warum nicht?
Ich habe es schon lange nicht genutzt.
Es ist seltsam, zurückzukommen und mit Millennium Edition zu verabschieden.
Ich kann mir das nicht vorstellen, was ich sagen würde, aber ja.
Ich verstehe die geateten Gefühle,
ich war schon da,
aber ich denke auch nicht, dass all das Hate auch nicht genutzt wird.
Das ist nicht zu sagen, dass ich es empfehle,
oder dass ich viel Liebe für es habe.
Windows 98 SE ist immer noch die bessere Wahl für PC-Gaming
von 1994 bis 2001.
Und dann geht es einfach mit Windows XP ab.
Aber es ist auch nicht das Ende der Welt.
Zumindest, wenn es sich an einem klaren, verträglichen System setzt.
Ich würde sagen, dass Windows ME eigentlich ein bisschen Spaß ist.
Und das guffe Turn-of-the-Millennium-Kind-Of-Way.
Und das ist wert, zumindest ein bisschen.
Wenn Sie dieses LGR-Video genossen haben,
dann glaube ich, dass Sie es wahrscheinlich schon gemacht haben.
oder wie dieses komische Ding hieß.
Das Zeug, da kannst du alles mögliche stylen.
Übels nice.
Und du hast dich damals auch wieder krasse Hacker gefühlt,
wenn du irgendwelche Registry-Dinger gemacht hast.
Und damals musstest du ja viele Sachen sogar noch direkt in der Registry machen.
Ja, das war schon nice.
Das war schon nice.
Was haben wir sonst noch hier zu bieten?
Burger.
Ich habe Hunger, Leute.
Ich muss Essen bestellen.
Backdoring-Smartphone-Kamera Windows XP.
Brain-Gutter-Power.
Was ein Stumpfsinn, warum soll man sowas denn machen?
Ich muss jetzt mal kurz gucken, was da rauskommt bei seinem Brain-Gutter-Power.
Ich meine, da kommt nicht sonderlich viel Regen.
Die Regenrenne runter.
Hier hat er es.
Guckt euch mal an.
Ernsthaft?
Das Ding gibt bestimmt wahnsinnig viel Energie.
Was will er damit betreiben?
Was will er damit betreiben am Ende?
Okay, ein cooles Hobbyprojekt, ja.
Wahnsinn.
Es dreht sich.
Was will er damit betreiben?
Damit kriegst du nicht mal einen Raspberry betrieben.
Kann er sein E-Auto aufladen?
Genau.
Ich überlege gerade, was könnte man Sinnvolles damit betreiben?
Vielleicht...
Mir fällt nichts ein.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, ein Temperatursensor im Garten oder so, aber das ist ja nicht dauerhaft.
Schau dir die Späte...
Okay, das heißt, es wird noch advanceder in den späteren Folgen.
Oh, es wird immer advanceder, Leute.
Es wird immer advanceder hier.
WTF.
Okay, wie viel kriegt er raus?
105 milliampere, 0.8 Watt.
Na ja, damit kannst du schon ein bisschen was anfangen.
Also für einen, sag mal so, für einen ESP32 reicht's.
Reicht's aus...
Ich überlege gerade, was, was könnte man damit schön betreiben?
Er guckt voll stolz.
Da kann man doch auch stolz drauf sein.
Das ist ja auch eine nice Geschichte.
Ich meine, so wirklich, ob da jetzt so wirklich was Sinnvolles mit betrieben werden kann, weiß ich nicht.
Mir fällt jetzt nichts ein.
Was man damit sinnvoll betreiben kann, was man an Stellen braucht, wo man ab und zu mal Energie über Regenwasser kriegt.
Könnte man da betreiben, vielleicht eine Pumpensteuerung für einen Teich oder so?
Wenn man da ab und zu mal irgendwas irgendwie Sauerstoff...
Keine Ahnung.
Und wenn es da nicht regnet, verrecken alle Fische oder wie?
Nee.
Also mir fällt jetzt gerade wirklich nicht viel Sinnvolles ein.
Die Regenmenge messen.
Das kannst du einfacher haben, die Regenmenge messen.
Da nimmst du eine Tonne und ein Ultraschall-Sensor.
Weil die Regenmenge messen tatsächlich gar nicht so schlecht ist.
Das wäre tatsächlich noch recht eine sinnvolle Geschichte damit, ja.
Eine LED, nee, nee, nee, da kannst du deutlich mehr als eine LED mit, da kannst du, da kannst du...
Naja.
Vielleicht, vielleicht eine LED-Strip, wenn du ihn ganz dunkel stellst, kannst du damit betreiben.
Ja, cooles, cooles Zeug.
Was? Tour of my home network.
Okay.
Was ist das hier?
Was hat er hier am Start?
Was hat er denn da?
Eine USB?
Irgendein Storage-Ding?
Und was ist das?
Ach, ist das, das ist eine Konsole, oder?
Ist das eine, das sieht aus wie eine Konsole.
Alter, was die Leute alles daheim haben.
Ich denke, ich denke schon immer, ich bin übertrieben, was ich hier am Start habe.
Mit meinem Mini-Rack und dem 10G-Switch und sowas.
Und dann sehe ich immer Leute mit ihren Patch-Panels und 48-Port-Switch.
Wobei, das ist kein 48-Port, das sind 24-Port-Switch, ne?
Ähm, ja.
Die gehen teilweise übertrieben ab.
Und das, ich, ich, ich hätte ja prinzipiell, fände ich es ja auch cool, mehr daheim zu betreiben.
Also ein richtig echter, cooler Hardware.
Aber das Problem ist, die Stromkosten sind es nicht wert für das, was man gewinnt.
Im NAPub-Haus kann man einfacher verlegen, das stimmt.
Stimmt! Jetzt ergibt das Sinn.
Jetzt das Wasser aus der Regengrinne.
Dann brauche ich, ja, dann ist easy. Easy.
5-Servo.
Das ist eine Konsole. Ziemlich sicher, das ist eine Konsole.
Sind das, sind das, sind das nur 2,5 Zoll?
Sieht aus wie nur 2,5 Zoll Platten.
Und ist eine USB.
Ich habe meine USB übrigens immer noch nicht repariert.
Ist immer noch ripp.
Moment, was ist das? Was ist da drinnen?
Langer.
Pick it up.
Und dann irgendeiner älteren Xeon. Was ist denn das?
Ein Dual-Core? Quad-Core? Keine Ahnung.
Aber 2x8G-Sustress?
Das ist kaum Speicher.
Und es zieht Strom wie Sau.
Ein Hex-Core. Okay, ordentlich.
So, das wird ein bisschen länger dauern.
Und unter dem haben wir meine APC 3000.
Bei der alten Kiste.
Ich habe sie nicht auf einem 30 Amp-Circuit runnen.
Also kann ich die 30 Amp-Circuit nicht auslösen.
Sonst wird es den Bremsgerät verpulsen.
Aber wieder, in einem nächsten Video,
ich will immer noch sehen, was das da oben ist.
Ich glaube, das ist eine Konsole.
Sieht zumindest aus wie eine Konsole.
Ja, es ist eine Konsole.
Exzellent.
Eigentlich komplett useless, wenn man das wie ich um die Ecke stehen hat.
Aber ich finde Konsolen cool.
Ich habe keine.
Ich brauche auch keine,
weil ich könnte einfach ein Monitor oben drauf stellen.
Überhaupt absolut unnötig.
Aber ich finde so ein Rack-mounted-Konsolen cool.
Was macht man mit dem Ding?
Das ist im Prinzip ein Notebook.
Das ist im Prinzip ein Notebook,
was du direkt an die Server anschließen kannst,
dass du Tastatur und Monitor für die Server hast.
Das ist nichts anderes,
als ein Tastatur und ein Monitor.
Du kannst genauso gut eine USB-Tastatur
und ein Monitor oben auf Rack stellen,
wenn das so ein kleines Rack ist.
Überhaupt kein Problem.
Viel, viel billiger.
Der Scheiß ist unglaublich teuer und eigentlich komplett sinnlos.
Aber ich finde so Rack-mounted-Konsolen trotzdem cool.
Und die ganzen Server haben ja heute noch VGA-Ausgänge.
Das ist übrigens kein VGA-Ausgang.
Das ist eine serielle Schnittstelle für die Konsole.
Aber das Super-Micro-Chassis gefällt mir.
So im Detail müssen wir uns das jetzt nicht angucken.
Dass er 8TB meint,
8TB Platten finde ich aber ganz schön viel.
8TB Sassplatten in dem ollen Ding.
Außerdem sind 8TB Sassplatten ziemlich teuer.
Gibt es keine zu kaufen.
Aber wenn er 8TB meint,
dann lasse ich mir gefallen, das zu betreiben.
Von wie alt das ist,
hätte ich mir eher 8TB vorstellen können.
Aber 8TB ist sinnvoller.
8TB ist noch älter.
Wenn das Sassplatten gewesen wäre,
hätte es so 300G oder 270G sein müssen.
8TB, okay.
Das war aber ordentlich teuer.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7 und vielleicht 8 hier unten noch.
8TB Sassplatten, das geht ein bisschen ins Geld.
Hast du schon mal die Rack-Hardware von Patchbox gesehen?
Finde die ganz cool, aber deutlich,
wenn man kein...
sagt mir jetzt nichts, nee.
Patchbox Rack.
Das da?
Sieht sehr stylisch aus.
Setup Excel.
Wollt lustig sein, okay.
Habe ich doch nie im Einsatz gesehen.
Sieht doch aber sehr stylisch aus.
Und sehr, sehr gut organisiert.
Ist ein Raspberry Pi als Grundlage
für ein einfaches Nass-Backup-System?
Nee.
Es sei denn, du hast keinerlei Ansprüche an dein Nass.
Dann schon.
Das Problem beim Raspberry Pi...
Also fangen wir mal an.
Wenn überhaupt, dann in den Raspberry Pi 4.
Alle anderen Raspberry Pis
waren sowohl netzwerktechnisch,
als auch plattenmäßig,
USB-plattenmäßig, was immer,
viel zu langsam angebunden,
dass man es ernsthaft als Nass in Erwägung ziehen könnte.
Beim Raspberry Pi 4 ist es ein bisschen besser.
Da ist jetzt alles ein bisschen schneller angebunden.
Zwar immer noch nicht so wahnsinnig schnell,
aber man kriegt halbwegs...
nicht richtig Gigabit,
aber sowas in der Richtung wie Gigabit
kriegt man raus.
Das Problem ist,
dass die komplett gespart haben
beim Raspberry Pi 4,
was die CPU angeht.
Die Arm-CPU,
die da drauf ist auf dem Raspberry Pi 4,
die hätte eigentlich Krypto-Extensions,
aber da haben sich
die Raspberry Leute gedacht,
die Krypto-Extensions, die lizenzieren wir nicht.
Der Raspberry Pi 4
mit Krypto-Extensions
wäre eigentlich ein ganz brauchbares Nass-System gewesen.
Und ohne Krypto-Extensions
ist halt die Frage,
wie sinnvoll ein Nass ist,
wenn man die Platten nicht verschlüsseln kann.
Wenn du wirklich nur
einen ganz basic Nass haben willst,
ohne Plattenverschlüsselung
und jetzt ohne wahnsinnig
große Performance,
dann kannst du den Raspberry Pi 4 nehmen.
Das funktioniert.
Aber das ist wirklich absolut
basic Nass, ohne dass man da irgendwie
großartig Sprüge mitmachen kann.
Und ich finde, den Nass brauche einfach verschlüsselte Platten.
Allein schon aus dem Grund,
weil man die Dinge einfach wegschmeißen kann,
wenn man sie wegschmeißen will.
Man muss nichts mehr machen, ja?
Wenn die Platte kaputt ist und du kannst die Platte nicht löschen,
dann musst du die Platte quasi erst mal zerstören,
weil du sie nicht überschreiben kannst,
wenn du auf Nummer sicher gehen willst,
dass keiner irgendwie deinen Passwortmanager ausliest
oder so, was Schwachsinn ist, was keiner für dich machen wird.
Aber wenn schon,
das könnte man so richtig machen.
Ähm...
Ja.
Ich würde...
Also wenn es ein Single Board Computer sein muss,
würde ich was anderes nehmen.
Ansonsten, irgendein Low End Celeron sind auch nicht schlecht,
habe ich ja auch gerade hier am Laufen.
Ja, das...
Und da kannst du auch wenigstens deinen Nass verschlüsseln,
und dann kannst du auch die Platte ein bisschen mehr durchschneiden.
Das könnte also bedeuten,
dass es ein bisschen mehr Bandbreite gibt,
aber es ist gar nicht so verkehrt, das muss ich jetzt vielleicht mal sagen.
Ja.
Ja, funktioniert wunderbar,
viel angenehmer als OpenVPN.
Synology ist okay.
Ich habe keins, ich hatte auch noch nie eins.
Aber alles, was man sieht,
scheinen die Dinger ganz okay zu sein.
10G.
Erstmal die Gordon Freeman-Bard.
PFSense.
PFSense habe ich...
rausgeschmissen bei mir.
Was würdest du empfehlen, damit niemand mehr auf eine alte Festplatte zugreifen kann?
Einfach überschreiben.
Wenn es noch geht, einfach überschreiben.
Einmal reicht.
Einmal überschreiben.
Oder einfach mal...
von Anfang bis Ende, dann ist weg.
Keine Chance, was wiederherzustellen.
Wenn du die komplett überschreibst.
Einmalig reicht.
Du musst die nicht 73 Mal, sonst wie überschreiben.
Einmal mit Nullen überschreiben und gut ist.
Was, Leute?
Guest Wi-Fi?
Wi-Fi for Guests?
Was habe ich jetzt?
Guest Wi-Fi.
Was ist da dran jetzt so lustig?
Chat, verstehe ich nicht.
Ach, hier unten. Guest Wi-Fi.
Wi-Fi for Guests.
Ja, das hätte man vorne nicht erkannt.
Der wollte halt überall,
wenn er da schon eine Klammer dahinter macht,
wollte er da auch noch eine Klammer dahinter machen.
Kannst du ein Tool dafür empfehlen?
Okay.
DDIF gleich DevZero
OF gleich DevSDC.
Keine Ahnung.
Was du da für eine Platte hast.
Dann noch BlockSize
und gut ist.
DD einfach drüber DD.
Nullen drüber DD über die Platte
und gut ist. Dann ist die von niemand
wiederherzustellen.
Also außer theoretische Maßnahmen
geht da nicht. Also
drüber komplett überschreiben.
Das ist sicher genug.
Was ist
DD?
DD.
Das ist bei jedem Linus
vorinstalliert. Hier, ups. Jetzt habe ich es ausgeschaltet.
Aus Versehen. Das ist bei
jedem Linus vorinstalliert. Das ist total simpel.
Du hast einfach DD, aber man muss aufpassen.
Das überschreibt dir auch, wenn du die falsche
Platte angibst.
Auch alles andere.
DD, IF, DevZero
OF gleich
Dev und hier machst du
die Platte rein.
Hier DevRAM. Haben wir das
geladen? Nee, haben wir nicht. Wie lädt man das?
Load RAM
DevRAM. Wie lädt man den Kram nochmal?
Wow. What the fuck?
Genau. Wie kann man
den Kram laden?
Ich lade jetzt mal eine mini RAM Disk, dass ich euch
zeigen kann, wie das funktioniert.
Was?
Was muss ich für
ein kernel Modul laden?
Load
RAM
Wie ging der Kram nochmal?
Modprop
Man konnte sich doch so mini RAM
Disks in Linux laden. Wie ging das
hier?
RAM1
Ah, ich hab
das.
Wie ging das hier?
Ja, genau. Den Kram will ich haben.
Welches kernel Modul braucht man dafür?
DevRAM
Genau.
DevRAM will ich haben.
DevRAM. Wie lädt man
den Kram?
Module
RAM Disk
Hier oder da?
RAM Disk Size? Nee, nee, nee.
Alter, das kann doch nicht so kompliziert sein. Da muss man irgendein
Modul laden und dann hat man den Kram.
Okay.
Ich bin grad zu noob style für
RAM Disk.
Was?
BRD?
Okay.
BRD
Und dann
hab ich jetzt
Dev
DevRAM
Ah, exellent.
Jetzt hab ich eine 1MB große RAM Disk.
Okay, jetzt kann ich euch das nämlich zeigen.
Also
Du sagst, wenn du eine Festplatte
Wir gehen jetzt mal davon aus, dass hier wäre meine Festplatte.
Sagst einfach If Dev
Zero Output Device
In dem Fall DevRAM
Zero. Dann sagst du noch eine Block Size
von 4K
Und das war's. Bam.
Bam. Fertig.
Ja, gut.
Das ist nur 1MB groß. Was auch immer.
Und zack ist die Festplatte leer.
Das dauert dann ein bisschen.
Das dauert dann
je nach Festplatte dauert das schon so 1-2 Stunden.
Oder schneller, je nachdem was für eine Platte ist.
Und dann ist weg.
Wir reden jetzt von Magnetplatten.
Nicht von SSDs. Auf SSDs kannst du eh nicht
so wirklich gut was her wieder herstellen.
Ähm.
Deswegen ist das auch cool,
weil man einfach standardmäßig Encrypted hat.
Dann kann man den Kram in Müll schmeißen und gut ist.
Also so. So.
Platte löschen. BS 4K.
Das geht schneller.
Ja. So.
Also was hat er? Was hat er noch?
Alles daheim. Wifi
für Guests. Das haben wir schon gesehen.
Also was verwende ich denn für
PFSense? Wie gesagt, ich habe meinen
PFSense schon vor 2 Jahren
oder so gekickt. Ich habe jetzt mal
einen Mikrotik-Router und gut ist.
Der macht voll happy Eindruck.
Guck mal, er hat auch einen UniFi
WLAN. Sehr schön.
Qualitativ super. Kann man empfehlen.
Ich habe auch 2 UniFi Access Points. Funktioniert wunderbar.
Ohne Count überschreibst du nicht
alles. Doch.
Ohne Count überschreibst du, überschreibst du alles
bis zum Schluss.
Oder nicht? Bin ich jetzt? Nee. Ziemlich sicher.
Überschreibst du alles ohne Count.
Oder? Machste nur einmal?
Nee, oder?
Nee, 100.
Du überschreibst alles, oder?
Nicht? Bin ich jetzt?
Ha!
Ich glaube, man braucht keinen Count.
Ohne Count macht er alles.
Probier es auf
Dev-SDA. Äh, wir können das
ein bisschen größer machen hier.
Oh, hier kann man anscheinend
Sachen angeben. Guck mal, wie groß
die RAM-Desk sein soll.
Huge.
RD-Size. Okay.
Machen wir mal. Modprobe
minus R.
Löschen wir den Kram mal wieder.
Jetzt ist Dev-RAM weg.
So. Jetzt machen wir das
gleiche wieder. Modprobe.
Ja.
BRD. Das da.
Das sind Bytes,
ne?
Was?
Ach so.
Sind das Bytes? So, wie groß
ist der Kram jetzt?
Wieder nur eins?
Warum ist es wieder nur eins?
Oh!
4,38G.
Exzellent.
Da können wir jetzt ordentlich draufhauen.
DD.
RAM-Zero.
4K. Block-Size.
Bam.
Der ohne Count überschreibt
da alles.
Ohne...
Ohne Count überschreibt da alles.
War so, wie ich das erwartet hab.
Wir können noch Procre...
Wie ging das? Procrest. DD. Procrest.
Stats. Stats. Procrest.
Können wir anzeigen lassen. Dann sieht man noch, was er macht.
Der
schreibt mit irgendwie 900 MB die Sekunde
jetzt 4GB
RAM voll. Easy.
Ist keine so gute Idee.
Weil ich hab
glaube nur
8GB RAM. Aber du siehst, so
kannst du deine Festplatte dir dehnen.
Einfach sagen, genau so wie ich es hier angegeben hab.
Dev-Zero. Hier
schreibst du das Device hin von deiner Festplatte
anstatt jetzt wo ich RAM-0 stehen hab.
Block-Size 4K ist gut.
Und Status, dass du siehst wie weit er ist und
drauf. Und dann läuft das Ganze
bisschen und deine Platte ist
geserot
und
nicht wieder herstellbar.
So ohne weiteres.
Eigentlich gar nicht wieder herstellbar.
So die
Dinger lohnen sich echt. Die UniFi-Dinger.
Die sind richtig gut.
Was hatte ich sonst noch am Start?
Braucht wahrscheinlich viel zu viel
Strom. Das sind so ehemalige Switche,
die die mittlerweile im RZ ausgemustert
haben. Und die Dinger sind halt
sehr leise noch stromsparend.
So ein Damenstart.
Die Idee bin ich noch gar nicht gekommen,
einen ESP
mit einem PoE-Splitter zu
betreiben.
Echt voll Energie...
Nein, was heißt Energie? Bei dem Bereich nicht wirklich.
Aber da musste 48 Volt
auf 3,3.
Dota-Joker. Ja, das meine ich.
Genau das. Das sind so die ollen Switche,
die alle schon ausrangiert haben.
FelixTegi, 8 Monate,
huge subscriber.
Nice, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Das ist vor allem ein riesen IoT-Device.
Was hat er da drin?
Was sagst du eigentlich zum neuen
Odroid C4?
Haben die neuen? Wusste ich gar nicht.
Müssen wir gleich mal gucken, ob es ein schönes Review auf YouTube gibt.
Ja, gucken wir uns gleich nochmal an.
Wir sind eh ganz schön lang heute am Start.
Kann das sein?
Drei Stunden schon?
Dann weiter geht's.
Wir gucken uns gleich mal an.
Alex,
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Zwei Monate, huge.
Alex143199999
Bist du...
Kennst du den Michael
500000000000
Euer Benutzername erinnert mich
irgendwie an einen anderen.
Dankeschön für zwei Monate Subs.
Huge.
Das ist die Ami-Wande.
Die Ami-Wende, ey.
Die Ami-Wende.
Probiert mal sowas bei euch
in die Wand zu kriegen.
Da stürzt vorher das Haus ein,
bevor ihr das in der Wand drinne habt.
Was hat er da ohne drin?
Löscher.
Eine Wand.
Was?
Das finde ich gut.
Es ist nie verkehrt überall Netzwerkanschlüsse zu haben.
Das haben wir hier im Haus
ein bisschen verkackt ehrlich gesagt.
Und das,
obwohl ich
es hätte eigentlich besser wissen müssen.
Wir haben nicht an allen
Stellen Leerrohre.
Und wir haben an viel zu wenig Stellen
Steckdosen und Netzwerk
Kabel gelegt.
Da bin ich selber dran schuld.
Da habe ich nicht richtig aufgepasst damals, als wir hier umgebaut haben.
Das war ein ziemlicher Fail von mir.
Ich werde das Video aufschneiden,
aber sie sind da unten.
Ich habe meinen
Soundbar, Subwoofer,
hier in die Wand gelegt
und versuchte es so gut
wie ich kann.
Das funktioniert.
Ohne Riesenakt.
Aber trotzdem zu wenig.
Beispielsweise komme ich jetzt
nicht so ohne weiteres
mehr Strom in Flur
oder
eine Netzwerkkabel
sagen wir mal jetzt an der Stelle vom Flur
bei mir ins Schlafzimmer, falls ich da irgendwie
einen
Schlafzimmer
in der Wand
habe.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Das ist halt sackt ein bisschen.
Hättest du die Wände aus
NA Pappe? Ja, das stimmt.
Ah, Custom Firmware.
Der Mann weiß wovon er redet.
Das ist so eine typische
NA Klimaanlage.
Ah, Home Assistant.
Der weiß wovon er redet.
Guter Mann.
Da hat er seine
UniFi Access Points.
Der hat es übrigens richtig gemacht.
Der hat hier an die Decke montiert.
Die Dinger
sind auch für Deckenmontage
gedacht.
Sowohl von der Charakteristik,
wie sich quasi das mit den Antennen da drinnen
verhält, als auch von den
Montagelöchern.
Die sind für Deckenmontage gedacht.
Und nicht wie bei mir, dass die auf
der Erde liegen.
Ubiquiti ist der Hersteller.
UniFi ist der,
die Serie von Netzwerkgeräten,
die sich über so einen zentralen Controller
verwalten lässt bei denen.
Was ich dir empfehlen kann,
Dota,
Joker, was
was bringt bei Reichweite ist,
wenn du statt 5 GHz WLAN
2,4 GHz WLAN verwendest.
2,4 GHz
WLAN
gehen ein bisschen leichter durch Wände durch
und gehen ein bisschen weiter als 5 GHz WLAN.
Das könntest du mal ausprobieren.
Ob das was bringt bei dir.
Was ist das für ein Dildo?
Ist das UniFi Controller?
2,4 GHz WLAN
ist aber absolut lahm.
Ach was.
2,4 GHz WLAN mit ordentlichem Empfang reicht locker.
Wenn ich die Auswahl habe
zwischen 5 GHz WLAN mit scheiß
Empfang, der laufend
abbricht,
zu 2,4 GHz WLAN mit
ausreichendem Empfang, dann ist klar, was ich nehme.
Äh, ist ein PoE.
Was?
Was konvertert das Ding eigentlich?
Converts?
Passive PoE Devices
into 802.3 AF?
Hä?
Was macht das?
Keine Ahnung.
Ah, verstehe.
Die UniFi-Dinger brauchen
special PoE.
Funktioniert.
Kein Grund, was du erinnern willst.
Ich bin jetzt im Carport
und ich habe
einen anderen UAP Pro hier.
Und dieser hier
ist, Entschuldigung,
die schlechte Digital-Zoom-Qualität.
Dieser hier ist,
also habe ich noch einen guten 5G-Signal
wenn ich hier draußen mache.
Ab dem Garten
ist kein WLAN-Empfang mehr
bei mir.
Und ich habe mir überlegt, ob ich nicht
in den Schuppen, also da
in die Werkstatt
ob ich da nicht noch einen Access-Point
stellen soll, aber ich bin so selten
im Garten, wo ich irgendwas mache, wo ich
WLAN bräuchte. Im Zweifelsfall habe ich
mein Smartphone mit und der hat 3G-Empfang
im Garten oder wahrscheinlich sogar
LTE-Empfang
im Garten, das brauche ich nicht unbedingt.
Das brauche ich nur, wenn ich auf irgendwelche internen Sachen
aus dem Garten zugreifen will und
das habe ich bis jetzt noch nicht.
So dass schön jeder
an die Sachen drankommt, wenn er mal kurz
über den Zaun steigt.
Excellent.
Wahrscheinlich hat seine Frau gesagt,
Alter, mach mal die Dinger hier weg.
So hässliche Elektronikgeräte
will ich nicht sehen.
Zu laut,
zu warm, zu hässlich.
Ich kann die
Abneigung von
gerade Mädels, ist es ja
zum überwiegenden Teil,
gegen nackte
Elektronikteile nicht verstehen.
Ganz viele,
also nicht nur Mädels,
es gibt auch genug, nicht so
technikaffine
Leute, die mögen
Technikteile, nicht die nach
Technik aussehen.
Also sprich,
wenn ihr da einen
Mac Mini hinstellt,
sagen die Leute, ah, yes,
Mac Mini passt, kann man hinstellen,
sieht schick aus. Wenn ihr dort
einen Raspberry Pi hinstellt,
mit einem durchsichtigen Gehäuse,
sagen die Leute, oh, Technikkram, macht es weg da.
Ja.
Ich verstehe die Abneigung gegen Technik,
die nach Technik aussieht, gar nicht.
Das ist doch gerade
viel besser, wenn die Technik nach Technik aussieht.
Hat er da.
Wow.
Exzellent.
Exzellent. Was hat er da am Start?
Irgendwelche
Relays, würde ich sagen, das sind irgendwelche Relays
zum Schalten von was auch immer.
Das ist ein Arduino,
ein oller Arduino, könnte das sein.
Oder es ist ein,
es sieht nicht nach einem Raspberry aus,
es ist bestimmt ein oller Arduino,
von wie fett das Ding ist und
von den Anschlüssen. Das ist
ein Uno oder so, ein alter Arduino,
ein Board mit
Relays dran.
Wo fällt dann so
ein Intel NUC hin? Ach, das ist wahrscheinlich
auch okay für die meisten Leute.
Wenn man in Technik nicht Technik sieht,
haben die meisten Leute damit wenig Probleme.
Das ist irgendwas zum draufklemmen.
Ich würde sagen, das ist ein Arduino,
der irgendwelche Relays
an und ausschaltet für ihn.
Der restliche Kram kein Schimmer.
Wenn dann mal das Dach
undicht ist, ja.
Das ist ein Arduino. Das ist ein Arduino
mit ein paar Relays,
so ein Relay Board zum Schalten.
Da stellt er
ein POE-Switch.
10G,
beste.
War doch ganz nett.
Was haben wir noch?
What can someone do with my
IP address?
Ich ahne Schlimmes, wenn ich das Video und die Titel
schon höre. Was hast du mit deinem
Exzellent? Ich hab sie nicht mehr alle.
Das ist das Problem,
was das angeht. Exzellent.
Oder gleich
schläft er ein.
Liegt.
Geil.
Erst mal
seine Public IP hinschreiben
und dann sagen, ich logge alle
IPs mit und zeige euch an,
oder was? What the fuck?
Das ist NA-Logik.
Mal ganz davon abgesehen, es kann ja
wohl kaum verboten sein,
wenn er
hier online öffentlich seine IP zeigt,
mal da mal ein Portscan
drauf zu machen, ein Portscan ist doch nichts Verbotenes.
Ja, Dotachoke, eigentlich geile Logik, oder?
Es kann überhaupt nichts passieren, keine Angst,
wenn ich verklag euch.
Ja, genug Werbung jetzt.
Was kommt denn jetzt?
DNS gab es damals auch schon.
Kifken.
8 Monate.
Huge-Subscriber.
Dankeschön.
Exzellent IQ-Subscriber.
Hi IQ-Chat heute wieder.
Nein!
Du wusstest, du hast für Google.com
noch nie die IP... What the fuck?
Das Ding heißt nicht umsonst Google.
Ok, vielleicht habe ich auch nicht richtig zugehört,
was er gesagt hat.
Das stimmt, das stimmt, hat er recht.
Ich habe es falsch interpretiert.
Ich dachte, er wollte mir damals erzählen,
er muss für Google die IP eingeben.
Ne, ne, der will wahrscheinlich auf DNS jetzt raus.
Ok, ne, ich habe Mist erzählt.
Was?
Also, ich kann mich an keine Zeit erinnern,
wo es kein DNS gab.
Echt nicht.
Also, es gibt Leute, die natürlich lokal
bei sich im Netzwerk keine DNS-Namen verwenden,
einfach IPs.
Ich habe bei mir auch nicht alles
DNS-Namen vergeben, wozu?
Aber alles, was online war,
ich kann mich an keine Zeit erinnern
und es wäre auch sehr, sehr merkwürdig,
wenn man dort
in seinen Browser IPs
eingegeben hat, statt Domains.
Seit es so diese normale
WWW-Browser-Geschichte,
man hat nur Domain-Names verwendet.
Was ein Schwachsinn.
Außerdem ist DNS überhaupt nichts Neues.
Ok, ok,
wenn er die Zeit meint,
wo es nur 5 Server im Internet gab,
dann ja, aber
das ist ganz schön schrecklich,
dass es so einen
so einen
Das ist ganz schön so fast stretched irgendwie
Now btx hieß das ding btx von der telekom btx
Everybody and every business every service anybody that has the internet has an ip address this is no news
So that is the legitimacy
Warte ich die xbox
Use for is to connect towards the recorder mit der nee jetzt läuft jetzt da unten die playstation was ist das da unten das läuft
Da unten war durch
Each other so i could be running a gaming server like i don't know minecraft server and
You, guys, would need, my ip address to connect and that's how
Addressing works das ist heute immer noch so getting towards its destination now that's the legitimacy of things but what about
malicious
things let's say for example i am running a website and you're gonna be needing my ip address so
Let's just say you obtain my okay, will you obtain, was will okay, was will uns eigentlich mitteilen
let's just say with
With, my ip address since you have it now
verdammt liegt
Okay, here's where things are gonna get what the fuck was will er eigentlich ich kriege anfälle von dem video
A little bit technical and before i get into that i just want to let it be known that if you guys are too skeptical of
When somebody has your ip and you keep getting booting offline or something worse is i do have videos of how
to protect yourself how to change your ip how to connect to a vpn on a computer or
a test by nord vpn sponsor
das erste was ich jetzt mal machen würde ist
Wie alt ist das video man an mf auf seine ip manne das ist zu alt die gilt in immer
ist erstmal ich machen würde ich erstmal mit port scan drauf machen und feststellen dass wahrscheinlich nix offen ist und
Ich nicht weiter gucken ich meine es kann natürlich auch sein dass was offen ist aber der port kann es nicht erkennt aber
Wahrscheinlich würde ich den pot scan machen und feststellen ist nix auf und tschüss
vergebende mühe
playstation on an xbox links will be in the description down below
So if you ever need to change your ip or get a vpn i do have tutorials on that i'll put in the description everything
resourceful
Ja, were you will be in the bad and a little bit more technical stuff so you have my ip address i mean yeah sure
if i didn't had a cisco
modem
Slash router router. Yeah, you'd probably be able to hit me off
Then all i'm gonna do is just unplug my modem and plug it back in then my ip address will change big deal
so if i nicht unbedingt
Also bei den ganzen kabel anbieter ist es zum beispiel nicht so
Had that i'd probably be easily hit off so
Is that it is that what else anybody could do is just knock somebody offline no there's there's so much more
Now this is ich bezweifle dass die meisten leute die kapazität und und
brain überhaupt dazu haben selbst wenn sie eine ip adresse von jemand haben damit auch eine ansatzweise
irgendwas zu machen
Was willst du damit großartig machen?
Selbst bei irgendwelche leute zu detausen ist nicht so einfach
In p mainly people on the console gaming all they know how to do is host boot they don't know how to run
x-plates they don't know how to take down a web server so is that something that everybody xbox p.s.
Flan wo führt das video noch in don't know actually how to root or a.k.a.
How to hack somebody or they don't exo exo über über die ip jetzt jetzt geht es aber ab
Also king wall ich bezweifle dass die meisten leute das überhaupt hinbekommen
Let's just get that straight if you find a host booter
Just all you gotta do is just change your ip if they keep saying you know all i'm gonna do is hit you offline
and that's
so
Let's talk about realistic
Hacking or oh ja erzählen tell me more in that case so
the person has my ip adress and
Was so gemacht ist videos der hälfte schon rum russis am i running am i running a web server am i running können wir das video
mit überspringen
Wir müssen jetzt gucken was da wie er gehackt werden will
Minecraft server am i running some type of server so
What they need to do ist
Kuss wort ja das habe ich mitgekriegt das war aber der wurde nicht
Gehackt also wenn es der fall ist den ich kenne der kuss wort schreibt gerade hast du mal von montana black damals mitbekommen
Da hat sich ja jemand in seinen stream geackten werbung gemacht
Soweit ich weiß wenn es der fall ist den ich mitbekommen habe hat hat sich keiner in den stream gehackt sondern
stream labs beziehungsweise die seiten wo er text to speech
notifications her hatte
Die hatten ihn nicht in den stream gehackt
Also die seiten wo er text to speech notifications her hatte die hatten irgendeinen fehler
dass man entweder die
Die die url die man braucht um um sachen anzuzeigen erraten konnte oder er hat die url mage liegt
Ich weiß nicht mehr es war es war irgendein fehler
Beim anbieter dieser dieser text to speech
notification geschichte
Das war nicht wirklich wo er gehackt wurde falls es das war
was ich im kopf habe
Es ist eh sehr schwammig ja so diese sachen wenn die leute ankommen ich hecke dich oder irgendwas was soll was willst du mir überhaupt damit mitteilen was
mein google account da lache ich aber mal drüber
Mein email account mein irgendwie willst du willst du mir was einschleusen auf dem rechner was was was genau eigentlich
Also so dieses dieses einfach nur hacken in den raum werfen ist es komplett komplett nicht sagen eigentlich
Es hat ein programm genannt n map zum beispiel zum beispiel wo man wo man von hacken in dem sinn sprechen könnte
Gehen wir mal von aus viele leute haben discord laufen ich sehe es hier unten auch gerade so gehen wir jetzt mal von aus
discord oder oder irgendein spiel hatten wir letztens mit der mit der mit der safe game lücke weiß ich ob ich das mitgekriegt
Hat mit der mit der safe game lücke gehen wir mal von aus discord oder ein spiel bei steam oder irgendwas
Das was was möglich viele leute benutzen so dass es auch interessant ist sich darauf zu konzentrieren
Das hat irgendwie die möglichkeit dass man im kontext dieses spiels beziehungsweise in dem kontext das jeweiligen benutzer
code ausführen kann
das ist was wo man dann wirklich von nennen wir es mal irgendwo
Dass man gehackt wurde in in irgendeiner art und weise und code ausführen alleine
ist ja auch noch nicht alles
Meistens muss man auch gucken dass wir irgendwie atmenrechte kriegt und wenn man keine atmenrechte kriegt dass man zumindest es irgendwie schafft dort
Sachen einzuschleusen die dann selbst wiederum im hintergrund laufen die auch weiterlaufen wenn das spiel dann beispielsweise aus ist und solche
die auch weiterlaufen wenn das spiel dann beispielsweise aus ist und solche geschichten
Das ist deutlich schwieriger als als das immer so hingestellt wird so nach dem motto ja jetzt wird es mal kurz gehackt
wirst du nicht
Das war vielleicht zumindest
98 zeiten so wo die leute noch einen modem direkt am direkt am internet hatten ohne jegliche
Na ohne jegliches nach davor ohne jegliche feierball davor direkt mit exposed sommer ports im internet so nach dem motto ja ok vielleicht
aber
das ist gar nicht so gar nicht so
so einfach wie sich das immer anhört
Es ist auch überhaupt kein problem den
Den virus
Bei einem auf den rechner zu bekommen kann es kann die irgendjemand eine email schicken mit einem virus im anhang
dass die datei mit dem virus auf dem rechner landet ist kein problem das ist easy as fuck das problem ist die datei muss
ausgeführt werden und das ist der eigentliche problem
Das ist das eigentliche problem das eigentliche problem bei viren ist nicht so sehr die viren auf den rechner zu bekommen sondern dass sie ausgeführt werden
Und dazu brauchst meistens sicherheitslücken oder dämliche benutzer die jeden scheiß anklicken also die quasi freiwillig ausführen
dass das überhaupt aktiv wird
so
Ja und gehen wir jetzt mal von aus beispielsweise discord das ist das was ich sagen wollte
Gehen wir mal gehen wir mal beispielsweise von discord aus wenn discord haben viele leute wenn discord jetzt irgendeine
schwachstelle hätte sagen wir impasen von
Dass sie den den chat text nicht richtig eskäpen so das war ja der fall beispielsweise bei montana black im stream mit
den einblendungen also mal angenommen die würden die würden die textnachrichten irgendwie
Inter noch mal verarbeiten und die nicht richtig eskäpen
Dann hättest du die chance über so wie es jetzt gerade bei apple mit den manipulierten mails und schon oftmals mit den
Manipulierten einmessages gewesen ist dann hättest du die chance dort irgendwas einzuschleusen allerdings müssen da mehrere
mehrere sachen
Mehrere sachen zusammenkommen ja nur weil die das nicht richtig eskäpen heißt auch lang nicht dass du was einschleusen kannst also das muss da nicht richtig
eskäpt sein und es müssen noch ein paar andere sachen
glückliche sich sich glücklich fügen sage ich mal dass das gut funktioniert
Einfachen was nicht richtig pasen ist nicht das problem wenn ich das dann allerdings nicht richtig gepasst in
ganz richtig in den exak rein stecke
Dann wird es problematisch
Und das ist alles nicht so easy wie sich das immer anhört so nach dem oder hier easy hack sonst wie rechner übernommen
Wie eskäpt man text richtig er kommt auch an was du was du machen willst also wenn du mann genommen du hast
Was hat man früher so machen du hast eine webseite auf dieser webseite kannst du irgendwelche kommandos eingeben
Und diese kommandos werden dann auf dem surfer ausgeführt
Gehen wir vom einfachsten fall aus sind schell kommandos so
den schell kommando sieht ja sieht ja so aus
ls schell kommando ls siehst du
Den inhalt vom verzeichnis auf dem surfer wird sie dann sehen gut mal genommen du kannst in ls einschleusen
Das ist ja nicht das was du machen willst du musst dann irgendwie gucken
dass du noch mehr ausführen kannst und zum beispiel kannst du anstatt einen befehl kannst du noch einen zweiten befehl anhängen mit
einem semikolon dahinter also sprich du kannst beispielsweise sagen ls minus la
semikolon reboot oder so
Irgendwas in der richtung soll das machen jetzt nicht ls minus la hier keine ahnung echo blub
so und mal angenommen der server passt diesen import hier falsch
und es kämpft das
Es kämpft hier dieses semikolon nicht man siehste an der stelle was passiert
Ergibt jetzt nicht etwa echo 2 echo 1 aus sondern ergibt echo 2 aus für einen neuen befehl aus
Echo 1 so und das ist halt wenn das nicht es kämpft das wenn das ganze es kämpft es ist kein problem dann führt er das richtige aus nämlich
echo und das als parameter
Kannst du mal bitte an ein minus a machen wills meine können wir es hier wissen
Gucken ob ich krasse können backs hab also die ich habe schon eine weile nicht mehr geupdatet monka es
Geweile nicht mehr geupdatet monka es das
Was steinecks da schreibt ich zeige euch mal kurz was das ist kein hack im eigentlichen sinne
Sondern ich muss nur gucken dass ich nicht ausführe aus versehen ich zeige ich zeige euch das mal kurz also das war steinecks hier geschrieben hat
ist es sehr beliebte sehr beliebte sache um leute zu ärgern die
neue in linux sind
Und zwar was es macht ist folgendes das ist eine fork bomb das sorgt dafür dass das system nach ein paar sekunden einfriert
Und zwar funktioniert das ganze folgenden folgendermaßen das ist eine funktion mit dem namen doppelpunkt
Und was die funktion macht ist das ist der body von der funktion
Also wir haben eine funktion die sich doppelpunkt nennt der name der funktion ist doppelpunkt dass es eine funktion das ist klammer auf klammer zu das ist best und tags
In ich könnte es jetzt theoretisch zeigen aber ich will mein ppega bord nicht nicht kaputt machen
Der body der funktion also sprich dass das das was die funktion ausführt ist folgendes es ruft eine funktion mit dem namen doppelpunkt auf
Also es ruft sich selber selber auf
Pipe den aus den output
nach
Noch mal einem aufruf der funktion doppelpunkt also was im prinzip zweimal die funktion doppelpunkt ist und macht das ganze im hintergrund so dass es nicht blockiert
So das ist abschluss der der quasi funktionsdefinition nächstes kommando doppelpunkt
So und was das macht ist hier fängt es an dass hier fängt an hier ruft es die funktion mit dem namen doppelpunkt auf
Die funktion mit dem namen doppelpunkt ruft sich selber zweimal auf und geht in den hintergrund und ruft sich selber zweimal auf
ruft sich selber zweimal auf ruft sich selber zweimal aus also sprich von einem funktionsaufruf sind wir bei
Trillionen billionen billionen zillionen was auch immer funktionsaufrufe und deswegen
Friert ihr einfach den rechner ein
Da passiert nichts schlimmes es friert ihr einfach der rechner ein
Du musst neu starten und selbst das klappt auf vielen modernen linux system nicht mehr weil die für normale user
ein
Prozess limit forklimate was auch immer gesetzt haben da passiert dann gar nix
Da passiert dann gar nix
So
Okay, gut
Mango united gaming twitch prime zum ersten mal subscriber dankeschön easy sub easy life nice
scan through the ports of my entire network is see what my
Ja mach ma ma ma passen so an an xbox port it's
3074 on a ps4 port war meine port scan
auf auf
report is but those are the gaming server ports with
macht er in dem video überhaupt noch irgendwas
scan through what ports are open and these are mainly ports of applications or purposes is
Somebody needs to they either have a private exploit or a public exploit, so I'm going to show you a public exploit site
So we're going to go to jetzt kommen die richtigen hackertricks db jetzt kommen die richtigen hackertricks. This is just all public
So these are all exploits so am I going to be running a web application
Remote exploits local and privilege explanation exploits
Es bringt doch keinem was wenn du überhaupt nicht wenn wenn du an der nutt ip vom router hängen bleibst
all service and pock exploits
Es gibt auch just pock exploits. We're going to talk about web applications. We're going to say I'm running a web server
for example
Ich weiß dass man ist poc schreibt bevor die leute will ankommen. Ich mags ja mal prove of concept
Aber ich finde ich finde pock exploits eigentlich viel besser
und
Okay, so this is the pathway
WordPress ist klar
Ich habe eine wordpress bei mir
Lokal auf dem windows rechner laufen in der alten version und haben port weitergeleitet von meinem router zu meinem wordpress auf meine windows
Excellent kannst du den bitte ja ich mache aus wirklich ein toffes video ist die ss
Es ist gar nicht also
Vom inhalt her ist das video gar nicht so schlecht. Ich glaube das problem ist nur
Dass derjenige der das ganze präsentiert gar nicht so richtig genau weiß wovon er redet
Obwohl ich bin ich sicher bin es könnte auch sein dass es einfach nur schlecht präsentiert hat was macht er was macht er denn sonst so
Da macht doch anderes hacker zeug also es ist durchaus möglich dass es einfach nur schlecht präsentiert ist
Netzdeutsch was on your network
Mit netz zed kann man übrigens nicht gucken was aus seinem netzwerk ist sondern nur was man lokal hat
Beziehungsweise verbindung die man lokal hat nicht was im netzwerk passiert
Okay, ob er sich jetzt auskennen und ich kann ich kann ich nicht keine ahnung kann ich nicht sagen das video war einfach nur schlecht aufbereitet
So
Übrigens für die ganzen ist das ebaro eigentlich da
Guckt mal was ich auf github entdeckt habe
Das ist was für euch leute gestern im chat noch gefunden ja
Das das das ist was das ist was für die für die wie fraktion hier unter uns
anime girls holding programming books was es nicht alles gibt auf github
Oder kommen jetzt zum beispiel gucken ok sondern sie schaab buch
Und ich wollte schon, weil immer das ach du große ach du wie spricht man das aus
Kuh kurumi
Zawa satan ich ja wie auch immer wenn ihr denn sie schaab buch hält das wollte ich schon immer was sehen
Was es nicht alles gibt oder auf github schon den cs go code gesehen ja habe ich
Was es nicht alles gibt oder
Den neuen otroid ansehen ja wollte ich wollte ich wollte ich wollte ich
Link bitte für freund ja suche ja anime girls holding programming books 7 2,4 karre sterne
Was es nicht alles gibt oder
Genau den otroid wollen wir uns angucken gibt es dann ein gutes video zu
Was just announced zwei vor zwei tagen ok
Was going on guys
Ich will dieses video kurz machen aber ein Auge auf den kanal behalten weil ich einen der japanischen
Hier wieder jetzt will ich dieses video kurz machen aber ein Auge auf den kanal behalten weil ich einen der neuen boards auf dem Weg habe
Und ich werde bald einen vollen review video auf dem kanal machen
Ich werde auch ein paar weitere folgen videos machen aber ich wollte ein bisschen ein
An
Stoff
Okay, was ist denn
Scheint mir der gleiche formfaktor wie ein raspberry zu sein da schon mal ganz gut
Es ist ein quad core aber ich hoffe die haben kripto extensions das ist das was wir beim raspberry pi 4 fehlt
Erljack und wir haben auch ein micro usb otg
Welches nicht viele Leute sich wirklich um sich Sorgen haben, aber es ist da, wenn man es nutzen muss
Was für ein Ding was für ein Ding
Utilisieren und das Board, aber es ist da, wenn man es braucht. Wir haben auch ein micro usb otg
Welches nicht viele Leute sich wirklich um sich Sorgen haben, aber es ist da, wenn man es nutzen muss
Und das Board wird von der Amlogic s905 x3 mit 4 gigas am
Jetzt habe ich Videos auf android boxen mit dem selben chip gemacht und ich persönlich wirklich mag es und das ist eine Sache
Ich bin wirklich was das problem ist von allen von allen raspberry pi clones
Die mögen zwar manchmal vom preis her günstiger sein die mögen auch von der hardware teilweise deutlich besser sein und durch dachte und alles aber
Der riesen vorteil vom raspberry pi ist der software support
Es gibt
Milliarden tutorials für raspberry pies es gibt ein super aktuelles debian was einfach funktioniert es gibt jede menge libraries die direkt die description von den
Raspberry sachen unterstützen alles der software support und auch der community support und alles drum und dran ist das was den raspberry pi ausmacht
Und da kommt ein anderes board einfach nicht mit
Außer es wäre komplett raspberry pi kompatibel was sie wahrscheinlich nicht sind
Android on this board. Wir haben micro sd card support und
Emmc support und das ist das ist cool. Das ist cool. Das ist cool
So boot times und loading das ist das würde ich mir wünschen dass der raspberry auch
so was anbietet
using emmc over st
Now there's a lot more information on this page die dresden pie eigentlich zwischendurch mit dem normalen upstream kone ich habe keine ahnung
Over some of their preliminary benchmarks now remember. These are in-house tests. I'll be doing the same test on my own
Just to see if they really stack up
But they've been really good about telling the truth in their benchmarks in the past as you can see here the raspberry pi 4
Is going to be in blue the odroid c2 is going to be in red
We'll have the xu4 in yellow the odroid in two in green and the all-new odroid c4 in orange
This is unix bench and as you can see we're not quite hitting xu4 speeds or the into
emm
Hatten wir uns dann haben den xu4 den haben wir doch hier im stream schon mal ausprobiert
Allerdings nicht in form von xu4 sondern in form von der platte
Das haben wir doch schon ausprobiert im stream da habe ich doch trüben die
Die den tv hat entserber gebastelt
Hab ich doch im stream gemacht sind wir sicher da haben wir den tv hätte installiert und das ist das ding was aktuell gerade bei mir
drüben im wohnzimmer liegt und
einen dual tuner usb stick dran hat
mit einer 2 mit einer
platte hinten dran
und was aktuell die
Aufnahmen was aktuell tv surfer für mein fernseher drüben ist das haben wir doch im stream gemacht
Das ist glaube ich ein xu4 unter der haube und er ist ziemlich geschwind ja da glaube ich gerne sogar
Viel langsamer vier schneller das ding war das ding ist richtig gut
Das dat da hatte ich den den tv hätte ein von meinem 4h e-server drüber abgelöst weil ich keinen bock mehr hatte alles so
single point of failure in einer großen kiste zu haben
Das haben wir im stream zusammengebaut ziemlich sicher
Da war uns tv hätte einen selbst kompiliert und es hat nicht richtig funktioniert kann ich mich noch dunkel dran erinnern
2 und der raspberry pi 4
Aber behalte diese in haus test ich werde die selben testen an meinem selbst nur um zu verifizieren
Als für unix bin ich zweimal präzision wir sind direkt auf dem par mit der raspberry pi 4
Aber die xu4 und die m2 haben uns immer noch ausgesucht
Die xu5 und die趣
Die haben schon mal nochmal ein kühler drauf noch ordentlich und das ist schon mal gute sachen visiting for
Sollte ich dann end luz darauf installieren
Android 9, warum
Wir haben Ubuntu
Ubuntu er sagt es richtig nicht Ubuntu
20.04, also wir haben den Main-Desktop und eine Minimal-Image
Ich weiß, dass viele Leute, die meinen Kanal reviewen, interessiert sind in Android zu laufen. Warum soll ich da drauf Android laufen lassen?
Wo ist das?
Wo ist der Sinn davon? Android benutze ich nur, wenn ich irgendwelche Android-Apps verwenden will und Android-Apps will ich auf einem Touch-Gerät verwenden und nicht auf
irgendeinem Single-Board-Computer-Dings, wo ich irgendwelche Services für mich im Netzwerk drauflaufen lasse.
They will have an Android 10 Image coming up for this in the next couple months. Now like I mentioned at the beginning of this video
I have tested an Android box with the same chipset and it actually does a really good job with Android Pie or Android 10.
Wenn man daraus ein Info-Display machen will mit Android-Apps, ja vielleicht, aber ganz ehrlich, bevor ich mir das Ding kaufen würde, um ein Info-Display mit Android rauszumachen,
da würde ich mir einen 45 Euro Fire Tablet kaufen, 7 oder 8, das ist das kleine oder das mittlere
und
dann hast du alles in einem
deutlich besser supporternden Plattform.
Win for this board because a lot of people just want to run Android, it's very simple to use, it's the world's most popular operating system, and all these Amlogic CPUs, it actually works really well, be it stock Android or Android TV.
And before I wrap this video up, I just wanted to go over the basic specs. For the CPU we have the Amlogic S905X3, this is a quad-core Cortex A55 CPU.
Das ist das gleiche wie im Raspberry, oder?
Ist das nicht auch ein A55 im Raspberry?
4?
Ach ne, A72 hat der, ok, was anderes.
Was mit meiner Maus los?
Funktion, ah jetzt, jetzt funktioniert, what?
What the fuck?
Chrome, Chrome bugged.
Das Zeug ist eh nirgendswo richtig supported.
Dieses ganze, die, die Raspberry GPU, da hast du ja auch ein bisschen Treiberprobleme.
Und um nicht zu sagen, Hardware-Decoding von Videos im Browser ist unter Linux immer noch absolut unding.
Also ich muss sagen, außer dass es ein Ticken billiger ist als der Raspberry Pi, sehe ich da für mich jetzt nichts, warum ich das bevorzugen würde gegenüber einem Raspberry Pi.
Der eMMC-Speicher vielleicht, aber eine Micro SD-Karte tut es ja im Endeffekt auch, wenn ich nichts Großartiges an AIO machen will.
Wenn ich was Großartiges an AIO machen will, mache ich da wahrscheinlich eine SSD dran oder eine Platte.
Und der Raspberry Pi ist einfach ungeschlagen, was Community- und Software-Support angeht.
Ich glaube, damit ärgert man sich eher rum, wenn man sich so einen Teil kauft.
Was mein ihr? Ich bin da, ich glaube nicht, dass das was ist, was ich mir kaufen würde.
Habe ich hier eigentlich so nice Chat-Messages dazwischen?
Schafft ja auch die Hannah-Montana-Distro, mit Sicherheit.
Die ist so alt, die läuft wahrscheinlich nur noch in VMs.
Boah Leute, ich bin vier Stunden on, das ist viel zu lang für sonntags hier.
So lang war ich ja noch, fast noch nie on.
Ich muss auch Essen bestellen, aber Essen kann ich nicht im Stream bestellen, weil da muss ich ja meine Adresse eingeben.
RIP.
Bestelle einfach mit Blackscreen, nee.
Ich gebe hier in den Browser nichts Privates ein, das ist mein Streaming-Account.
Auf dem Handy, lull.
Ja, das könnte ich tatsächlich machen.
Ich bestelle einfach vor meinem zweiten Rechner.
Ich weiß aber nicht, was ich bestellen soll, Leute.
Ich bin unschlussig, was ich bestellen soll.
Wir müssen jetzt mal kurz überlegen, was ich bestellen könnte.
Ich kann mal kurz überlegen, also ich gucke mal, was auf hat.
Italienische Pizza in Hülle und Fülle.
Döner, Döner hätten wir zu bieten.
Döner-Mann ist am Start.
Jede Menge Pizzeria, Pizzeria, Pizzeria, Pizzeria.
Ähm.
Döner-Mann ist am Start. Jede Menge Pizzeria, Pizzeria, Pizzeria, Pizzeria.
Fried Chicken.
Sushi, nee, Sushi habe ich jetzt keinen Bock drauf.
Eis, nee.
Pizza Hut, geh mal fort.
Wobei, ich muss sagen, jetzt wo ich jetzt erstmal schon gelässt habe, Pizza Hut.
Jedes Mal, ich gehe selten zu Pizza Hut.
Ja, und ich bestelle auch selten bei Pizza Hut was.
Aber jedes Mal, wenn ich Pizza Hut bestelle, schmeckt es mir besser, als ich gedacht habe.
Köfte kann man bestellen.
Domino's ist richtig eklig geworden.
Joey's Pizza ging ganz gut, aber Domino's ist in Deutschland richtig abartig.
Indisch, Indisch und China Service. Gibt's?
War nicht schlecht.
Asiatisch, Vegetarisch?
Das war's, was jetzt auf hat.
Ich glaube, ich bestelle mir ein Döner Teller und Gutes.
Was ist der Mindestbestellwert?
Was ist Mindestbestellwert?
Döner Teller mit Knoblauchsoße scharf, jawoll.
Pompfrit oder Reis?
Chat, Pompfrit oder Reis beim Döner Teller?
Was ist bei euch lieber? Ich esse beides ganz gern.
Reis, Reis, Pommes, Pommes, Pommes, Reis, Pommes.
Oh, 50, 50.
Pommes überwiegt, Reis.
Ich würde sagen so 60% Pommes, 40% Reis.
Pommes kommen weich an? Nee, bei dem nicht.
Der ist nämlich Luftlinie, 10 Meter von mir weg.
Ich hab da schon öfters bestellt.
Also ich bestell jetzt wirklich online bei einem Laden, der 10 Meter weg ist.
Keck, weh.
Kannste selber holen, der da muss Streamer ausmachen.
So hinzufügen, yes.
Oh, 2 Euro Mindestbestellwert.
Fuck, was mach ich denn jetzt, was bestell ich denn da noch?
2 Euro Mindest, ich kann doch einen Ayran dabei bestellen also.
Ayran.
Ah, der kostet nur 1,30. Tja, dann wird das nix.
Was? Uludak, was ist das? Ist das türkisches Bier?
Ist das das türkische Bier?
Nee.
Türkische Phantasprite, oh nee.
Ich mag ja schon NA Sprite nicht.
Weiß nicht, ob die türkische Fake Sprite dann besser ist.
Ich weiß nicht. Leute, wisst ihr was?
Ich bestell jetzt nicht im Stream. Ich mach jetzt den Stream aus.
Ich hab richtig lang gestreamt heute und wir sollten jetzt alle wach sein.
4 Stunden, 3 Minuten.
Und jetzt geh ich erst mal in Ruhe aufs Klo kacken.
Und dann geh ich Essen bestellen.
Ja, süße Leute. Ja, ja, ja. Ihr seid alle nicht wach. Ich weiß, ich weiß, ich weiß.
Ja, danke für alle, die dabei waren.
Ich guck mal kurz, ob wir irgendjemand hosten können, dem ich followe.
Ob da irgendjemand am Start ist, der kleiner ist und...
Ähm, nicht wirklich.
Nicht wirklich. Gut, also dann.
Ich glaub, ich hab keine Subs übersehen.
Schön, dass heute wieder so viele Leute dabei gewesen sind.
Morgen ist Schluss. Wir sehen uns vielleicht sogar morgen schon wieder.
Morgen hab ich ja frei, weil Montag.
Also bis dann. Macht's gut. See you.